cigare live bonsoir il est 21h55 nous
sommes en direct emmanuel macron et
marine le pen sont au deuxième tour ils
sont qualifiés jean luc mélenchon est
troisième mais je ne vous refais pas
tous les résultats au niveau national
parce qu'ici on vous donne le résultat
de votre commune je suis avec adrien
brillant adrien des médias sociaux du
figaro bonsoir dragon sorti bonsoir à
tous merci de ma compagne on va passer
un peu plus de deux heures ensemble
alors c'est très simple vous laisser un
message sur sur le chat celui du
figaro.fr celui de youtube celui de
facebook celui que vous voulez dans ce
message vous nous demandez la commune
dont vous souhaitez connaître le
résultat adrien vous lit il me transmet
le nom de la ville et puis on cherche
comme ça que ça se passe exactement et
vous allez être très nombreux ce soir en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on espère on a mis
quelques règles de modération donc sur
facebook sur youtube et sur lefigaro.fr
donc vous ne pourrez pas à commenter 14
fois par seconde
le nom de votre ville en espérant passer
devant les autres ne vous en faites pas
on va essayer de prendre le maximum de
ville je vois je vous rappelle aussi
quelques règles de bienséance soyez
courtois éviter les insultes entre vous
et oui on essaie on passe un bon on va
passer un bon moment ensemble loire
alors vous présente comment ça va
fonctionner on va être sur cette image
toute la soirée et vous pouvez vous
aussi sur le site du figaro.fr allez
trouver le résultat dans votre commune
ici on peut rechercher le lieu d'une
ville on va donner un exemple très
simple très rapidement adrien donnez moi
le nom d'une ville vous vous êtes nés ou
moi je suis né à lorient dont le mans
vie alors lorient lorient c'est
peut-être une trop grande ville je vous
précise aussi que les plus grandes
villes arrivent plus tard d'abord parce
que les bureaux de vote ont fermé plus
tard et parce que les dépouillements
sont plus longs mais on va essayer
lorient est ce que à lorient on a déjà
des résultats eh bien voyez pas encore
on n'a pas encore les résultats à
lorient en 2022 non ils ne sont pas
encore arrivés on a ce 2017 on va
pouvoir comparer un tout au long de la
soirée par rapport au premier tour de
2017 sachez qu'à lorient il y a cinq ans
et emmanuel macron qui est arrivé en
tête devant jean luc mélenchon et devant
françois fillon on pourra comparer on
essaiera aussi tout au long de la soirée
de réviser un peu nos géographies 1 je
sais que vous êtes vous êtes excellent
là dessus quand quand vous avez des
premières villes qui tombe avec des
premiers internautes qui nous pose des
questions je vous préviens aussi que
vous pouvez suivre sur le figaro leila
la grande soirée de la présidentielle
avec bruno dre avec vincent rosereau
nous rejoindrons d'ailleurs dans
quelques minutes
adrien est ce qu on a déjà une ville
qu'on peut me thibault huit mois nous
avons romney au mma y dans le 71 alors
je vois plusieurs personnes qui précise
le numéro du département merci puisque
effectivement ça va bien nous aider ce
soir et bien voilà revenez voyez on a
les premiers résultats alors sachez
qu'un romney marine le pen fait un très
bon score 37% devant emmanuel macron et
devant jean-luc mélenchon eric zemmour
arrive en quatrième position on a amené
même si les scores sont un peu
différents les quatre premiers de la
même manière jean lassalle qui arrive
avec presque 4% des voix la salle qui a
fait un très bon score c'est plus
difficile pour valérie pécresse nicolas
dupont aignan yannick jadot etc etc
c'est philippe poutou avec seulement
huit voix ar menez qui est qui est
arrivé en dernière position ont mené
sachez le couvre une superficie de 49
kilomètres carrés voilà on peut savoir
tout ça sur le sur le site sur le site
du figaro on a ce genre de détails mon
nous avons marie amélie qui nous
demandent qu'à auch cahors
alors bien sûr dans le lot cahors le
résultat on l'a aussi c'était manuel
macron qui est en tête comme au niveau
national jean luc mélenchon très bons
scores à cahors 1 2650 trois voix c'est
au coude à coude il ya à peine une
cinquantaine de voix d'écart marine le
pen est troisième avec 1712 voix à
cahors eric zemmour juste devant yannick
jadot six en six ans une voix valérie
pécresse jean lassalle fabien roussel
cette fois c'est nathalie arthaud je
pense que tout au long de la soirée on
risque d'avoir à nathalie arthaud et
philippe poutou d'un dans les dernières
positions on verra si il y à des
communes où nathalie arthaud lo et
philippe poutou ne finisse pas dernier
on peut comparer à l'est on compare
adrien avec 2017 y est arrivé en tête au
premier tour s'était également emmanuel
macron devant jean-luc mélenchon
finalement on va continuer à voter à peu
près pareil à cahors
alors je vois fabienne qui nous
demandent des résultats dans le 57 alors
pour les départements ça va être
compliqué et tant qu'on n'a pas tous les
résultats on ne peut pas vous les donner
mais sans doute plus tard dans la soirée
c'est important de le préciser on ne
peut pas donner un département tant
qu'il n'y a pas toutes les communes de
ce département donc des fois bien
souvent même dans la soirée ça peut
paraître compliqué il faudra peut-être
même attendre demain matin pour avoir le
résultat complet d'un département alors
ici j'ai une plus petite ville roura
roja rera dans le 97 ça comment on
appelle les habitants de rouvre à 6
alors peut-être une réponse si elle est
toujours là oui alors n'hésitez pas à
vous en vous relance alors rouvrons
brassée en guyane figurez vous voilà je
vois ça oui oui 97,3 évidemment aux
roues alors à rouvroy c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui a fait un très bon score
dans les dom-tom 38,28 % emmanuel macron
158 voix avec 20 % devant marine le pen
et eric zemmour qui arrive en dernière
position c'est nathalie arthaud avec
cette voie on fait un petit panorama
complet la gauche en difficulté aussi à
part jean luc mélenchon dans cette
commune qui fait un très bon score 299
fois c'est une petite commune roja et on
cherchera comment on appelle les
habitants droit est ce que google
wikipédia peut nous donner la réponse
tient on est sur wikipédia on va
chercher
ce que j'arrive à trouver ça comment on
habite en appelle les habitants de deux
roues est peut-être parti dans quelque
chose qui va me va le dépasser mais
peut-être pas trouvé bon on cherchera
plus tard les habitants de roura ce que
vous avez une autre commune alors rien
nous avons beaumont dans le 63 alors
beaumont dans le 63 et vous pouvez le
faire j'ai mené de cynthia sur facebook
alors on regarde à la fois sur le site
sur youtube et sur facebook à beaumont
emmanuel macron en tête 25 voix c'est
une toute petite ville vous avez vu dix
sept voix c'est la plus petite ville
qu'on a eu depuis le début
beaumont est ce qu'on a le nombre
d'habitants 133 habitants à beaumont je
vais noté voyez j'ai un petit carnet ici
et je vais noter la plus petite ville on
verra si on arrive à voir encore plus
petit que beaumont dans des communes
comme ça il ya des candidats qui peuvent
faire zéro voir on va voir on va
descendre et ouais c'est le cas on
regarde et philippe poutou valérie
pécresse zéro voix à beaumont tout comme
nathalie arthaud tout comme nicolas à
non nicolas dupont aignan et anne
hidalgo y voir une voix eh ben c'est pas
si mal c'est bien on sauve l'honneur à
beaumont et donc c'est emmanuel macron
qui est en tête devant marine le pen
comme au niveau national vous avez vu
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
égalité à beaumont alors nous avons anne
qui profitent de devoir le commentaire
de
de cynthia sur beaumont pour nous
demander et bien hénin beaumont 62 sur
hénin beaumont un peu plus grands déjà
hénin beaumont c'est c'est le fief de
marine le pen est ce que marine le pen
sur ces terres là où elle a voté ce
matin fait un bon score
résultat tout de suite on descend la
page et on n'a pas encore les résultats
on n'a pas encore les résultats hénin
beaumont on le rappelle adrien dans les
plus grandes villes c'est plus compliqué
oui donc on ira faire un tour un peu
plus d'avoir 2010 est quand même là il
fait un très bon score à marine le pen
presque 2 50% des voix 46 5% des voix à
hénin beaumont c'est là où elle est élue
députée d'ailleurs on verra si la
tendance se confirme pour marine le pen
sur cette élection 2022 nous avons
béatrice qui nous demande sur facebook à
brest alors ab est restée dans le 0-3 à
brest dans le dans le 03 alors à brest
qui nous demandent ça vous m'avez dit
c'est béatrice béatrice de l'allier
emmanuel macron est en tête à abrest
29,31 progressé très serré ans trois
fois de plus à peine que marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon est troisième eric
zemmour quatrième le même résultat que
au niveau national valérie pécresse 4%
jean lassalle également fabien roussel
le petit score de yannick jadot voyait
seulement 2 46% des voix à abrest anne
hidalgo philippe poutou et nathalie
arthaud 9 9 voix pour elle dans cette
commune a on peut voir la participation
aussi regarder dans toutes les communes
on va s'y attarder parce que c'est peut
être intéressant 79 points 62% des voix
on est à peu près dans la moyenne
nationale ouais même un peu mieux quand
même hein parce que ça fait 20,38 %
d'abstention on est notre tension autour
de 25 % 1 donc on a bien voté par
rapport au niveau national dans cette
petite commune d'à brest dans dans
l'allier
alors il faut que je lise le commentaire
dany qui nous dit merci à vous tous au
figaro que ferions nous sans vous merci
à mes demandes mais que ferions nous
sans les internautes qui nous posent des
questions c'est vrai c'est vrai alors
prenons maintenant aller dimitri
d'immunologie sur bresle alors alors dit
comment l'en jseb les as et un bep blanc
gsb lan j' y sûr
je le vois je vois blangy sur bresle
alors avant de vous donner les scores on
va on va essayer de trouver blangy
blangy-sur-bresle sur une carte de
france je trouve ça pas mal de voir on
révise la géographie alors
blangy-sur-bresle déjà c'est en seine
maritime
voyez et donc s'ils ont des zooms un
petit peu mais on n'est pas très loin de
la mer on est on est entre amiens et
dieppe voilà à blangy sur bresle et donc
à blangy-sur-bresle marine le pen très
bon score 41 49 % dans toutes les
communes qu'on a vu depuis tout à
l'heure c'est ses meilleurs scores qu'on
a vu dans une commune 636 voix devant
emmanuel macron devant jean-luc
mélenchon et après sa chute évidemment
eric zemmour qui ne fait que 4 37% des
voix il ya peut-être un rapport avec ce
très bon score de marine le pen
lorsqu'on descend vous voyez jean
lassalle yannick jadot nathalie arthaud
une nouvelle fois dernière de 2,7 de
cette commune alors l'abstention c'est
pas terrible 60 31 % d'abstention c'est
plus qu'au niveau national dans dans
cette commune de seine maritime de
blangy-sur-bresle voilà dimitri
alors nous avons fabienne qui nous
demande toujours sur facebook alors sur
youtube vous êtes un peu plus timide
n'hésitez pas à nous donner les les noms
de vos communes et
alors fabienne sarreguemines à
sarreguemines s à 2 0 je vois très bien
sarreguemines dans 157 exactement alors
c'est
pas certain qu'on ait encore les
résultats et oui on à sarreguemines
c'est trop grand vingt mille huit cent
vingt habitants et on le rappelle les
communes où il y a plus d'habitants
elles sont plus longues à dépouiller
comme à sarreguemines où bureaux de vote
ferment à 19 heures et même pour les
plus grands le bureau de vote à fermer à
20h alors c'est encore plus compliqué à
sarreguemines sachez qu'en 2017 emmanuel
macron avait remporté le deuxième tour
dans ce projet très on en parlera à la
semaine prochaine de ça et c'était
marine le pen qui est arrivé en tête
devant emmanuel macron il y a cinq ans
alors j'ai le havre ici mais ça sans
doute être trop grand le havre c'est
trop on va essayer quand même pour vous
venez sera essayons un regard on
rappelle et vous pouvez le faire aussi
chez vous parce que nous on vous aide
mais on va pas pouvoir répondre à tout
le monde probablement vous tapez vous
allez sur les résultats vous trouver
très facilement sur la page d'accueil du
figaro vous recherchez le résultat à
droite le havre comme ici et vous avez
donc les résultats et bien voyez vous
êtes mauvaise langue parce qu'au havre
on a déjà les résultats et au havre
surpris c'est la première fois depuis
qu'on a commencé ce direct jean luc
mélenchon c'est lui qui est qui est en
tête c'est lui qui est en tête 30,17 %
des voix
vingt mille neuf cent voix quand même
pour jean luc mélenchon dans une commune
rappelle edouard philippe et mer donc
emmanuel macron ne fait pas le meilleur
score au havre et c'est à cette à noter
27 53% des voix marine le pen 3e éric
zemmour beaucoup plus bas on voit se
détacher un peu partout c'est parce que
vous en pensez adrien c3 c3 personnages
ces trois candidats assez largement on a
tout de suite à un gap 1 derrière on l'a
vu au niveau national et ça se confirme
évidemment logiquement sur sur les
communes 31,77 % d'abstention on n'a pas
très bien voter au havre alors on a eu
de la chance au havre alors on va
peut-être tentés au parc aubagio sur
facebook max nonoban bien sûr aubagne
dans les bouches du rhône évidemment 47
mille habitants et voyez comme quoi
voilà quarante sept mille habitants on
n'a pas de résultats à aubagne on va
quand même aller voir ce qui s'est passé
en 2010 est pour qu'on pour comparer
c'était marine le pen en tête on sait
que dans le sud de la france lorsque le
prince qui s'appelle front national à
l'époque car on le voit ici on n'avait
ni front national à aubagne et bien
c'est marine le pen qui était arrivé en
tête
nous avons kevin qui nous demandent
chemy chemille chu mi-2011 munch mi mai
et avaient entre une chemise et une
chenille et une chemise ce mieux comme
ça alors je trouve pas cheminer dans le
chef jean louis dans le 49 alors ces
chenilles est mêlé c'est ça
kevin qui est sans doute toujours kevin
les jours avec nous qui a commenté il ya
une minute oui c'est bien ça c'est
hachémi de celle là bas si vous me dites
que c'est dans le car on en a 49 me
mêler une petite commune cheminée mêlée
on n'a pas encore le résultat dans cette
commune alors c'est vrai j'ai commencé à
regarder un peu tout à l'heure avant
commençait ce direct il y a des fois des
petites communes des anomalies ou on n'a
pas encore les résultats m'ont les zorra
et n'hésitez pas à vous revenez un peu
plus tard vers 23 heures et on cherche à
nouveau promis kevin c'était surcroît
kevin sur youtube c'était sur facebook
et va sur facebook et vine y revient
dans une petite heure il nous redemande
chemillé on en joue et on y va je me est
mêlée et on y va et on est on trouve
alors sur youtube puisqu'on va on va
équilibrer un peu je vois signes qui
insiste beaucoup pour avoir le blanc
mesnil le blanc mesnil est ce qu'on a
déjà les résultats au blanc mesnil
c'est la suze cherche alors le
blanc-mesnil il faut peut-être mettre
des tirs et vous savez
est-ce que j'ai le blanc-mesnil gelé ici
dans le 93 évidemment la seine saint
denis on n'a pas encore non plus les
résultats au blanc mesnil est-ce que qui
était en tête en 2017 au blanc-mesnil
c'est jean luc mélenchon sans trop de
surprise il ya des départements et des
villes qui sont plus favorables à marine
le pen de plus favorable à jean luc
mélenchon on surveillera on reviendra
tout à l'heure sur le sur le blanc
mesnil 16 1643 électeurs en
seine-saint-denis à l'époque on verra si
on a bien voté au blanc-mesnil tout à
l'heure
qu'est ce que je peux vous donner
d'autres dissidents a dit nous avons
alors yannick qui nous vient du jura et
ils demandent champagnole champagnole
champagnole dans le jura donc exactement
39 et bien allons-y à champagnole est ce
que on a un résultat oui on a un
résultat assez serré d'ailleurs à très
serré un match à 3 1 comme vous pouvez
le voir marine le pen 26,36 emmanuel
macron 24,57 jean luc mélenchon 22,78 on
n'est pas loin des 1000 voix pour ces
trois candidats c'est eric zemmour qui
arrive en quatrième position devant
valérie pécresse jean lassalle 1
décidément il a fait un bon score jean
lassalle plus mais mieux que d'autres
mieux que le parti socialiste au niveau
national et ça se confirme ici fabien
roussel anne hidalgo philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud en dernière position on
a plutôt bien voter dans le jura à
champagnole
23,79 % des électeurs de champagnole ne
se sont pas déplacés
là il va falloir que je voulais pelti
beau jeu nous avons kalisa sur facebook
je suis demande oui soisy sous
montmorency
déjà si vous avez du mal à le dire je
vais avoir du mal à le taper soisy alors
choisi sos y est ce qu il s y sous alors
il ya des sur iliad et souriez soit
garanti sur un sous montmorency
exactement rien même pas besoin de taper
noyer vous avez tout ça sur le sur le
site du figaro soisy sous montmorency et
on n'a pas encore le résultat dans cette
commune
alors on a toutes les informations en
plus vous pouvez même savoir les impôts
on recense le nombre de foyers fiscaux
vous pouvez tout savoir sur ces communes
ce qui donne peut-être à une idée un peu
soul sociologique de l'électorat de
soisy sous montmorency n'y en a pas
encore les résultats on viendra voir
tout à l'heure dans le val d'oise si on
a si on a d'autres résultats à
soisy-sous-montmorency dites moi vous
avez notre ville oui alors on à
guillaume qui s'étonnent qu'il n'y ait
pas d'aléa siens dans le chat et on lui
demande le résultat dans la ville
d'haguenau haguenau sens avec un achat
hagen exactement achats est-ce qu'on est
ce qu on serait pas un concours entre
nos internautes pour savoir le
département qui est le mieux représenté
pour l'instant on a eu un peu de tout je
crois pas qu'on a un département qui
demandent plus sa commune que d'autres
on va on va scruter on va regarder ça à
haguenau est ce qu on a un résultat oui
on a un résultat à haguenau très bon
score des manuels mâcon
31,39 % dans le bas-rhin dans cette
ville d'haguenau marine le pen 27,65 %
des voix jean-luc mélenchon il est plus
bas voyez ici 15 points 67 score correct
d'eric zemmour à correct en tout cas par
rapport à d'autres résultats qu'on a pu
voir avant 7,46 % pécresse jadot dupont
aignan la salle hidalgo roussel artaud
et c'est philippe poutou qui est dernier
dans cette commune avec 102 voix
abstention élevée 28,51 % des habitants
d'haguenau alors est ce qu'on ressent
très pas pour savoir comment on appelle
les habitants d'haguenau vous avez une
idée fait un pari d'ailleurs les ags
noah s'est sans doute pas du tout ça les
haguenau et les internautes vont
corriger tout de suite vu aussi longs
wikipédia oui mais wikipédia et surtout
ils y habitent alors eh bien
figurez-vous on a demandé qu'on appelle
des réponses alors regardez regardez les
habitants ici là où je mets la souris
alors c'est peut-être un peu petit les
haguenovienne et les haguenoviens très
bien honnête j'étais bien moins jeunes
mais que c'était un peu difficile
haguenau donc dans le bas rhin et on
verra si les alsaciens sont représentés
sur
sur ces différents chat je vous rappelle
que vous donnez le nom de votre commune
vous le donner et bien sûr les tchats du
figaro sur le chat de youtube sur le
chat de facebook adrien me les donne on
transmet et ont cherché guillaume voilà
qui nous remercient qui nous dit
classiquement la gauche est assez basse
en alsace donc voilà il n'est pas pas
sûr qu'un pape a surpris pas surpris des
résultats alors la grosse ville alors je
suis pas sûr qu'on l'ait versailles
alors adrien je vous coupe une petite
seconde parce que je vais saluer dans un
instant
oui je vous explique on est en train de
nous lancer sur un autre live live de
bruyne d'audrey et vincent rose rond
donc on cherche les résultats ici je
salue les internautes qui suivent cette
grande soirée avec vous brunet et
vincent alors c'est très simple ici vous
nous demandez sur les différents chat le
nom de votre commune adrien ou les
transmet et puis on donne le résultat on
essaye de trouver tout à l'heure on a
cherché comme on appelait les habitants
d'haguenau les haguenoviens des
haguenovienne en alsace alors dites-moi
adrien est ce qu on a eu notre commune
qu'on peut qu'on peut chercher pour
essayer de donner un résultat alors nous
avons senseo sur sur facebook qui se
réveille drame avait des airs avait eu l
essai dans le 91 draveil de senseo eh
bien on passe le bonjour snc va
l'envoyer des fois ça arrive on n'a pas
le résultat comme ici pas encore on
attend vous revenez un peu plus tard
dans une petite heure vous nous
redemander le résultat à draveil dans
l'essonne est ce qu on fait généralement
quand on n'a pas les résultats on essaye
quand même de se renseigner pour savoir
quel avait été le score il y à il ya
cinq ans et il ya cinq ans et emmanuel
macron vous le voyez qui est arrivé en
tête avec 25 59 % des voix devant
jean-luc mélenchon et on peut comparer
on peut voir si ça a évolué si les
électeurs ont changé d'avis où ils sont
ils sont restés dans la même veine
est-ce qu'on a une autre commune alors
on a un premier un premier commentaire
sur le sur le site du figaro n'a pas
encore pris de commentaires donc on va
vendre allons-y de pragma qui nous
demande les résultats pour me dont
meudon alors on rappelle me dont
assez grande pas sûr qu'on ait des
résultats exactement les villes les plus
grande soit elle ont fermé plus tard
pour les vraiment les grosses villes les
bureaux de vote ont fermé aux alentours
de 20 heures soit vers 19 heures les
bureaux de vote sont fermés mais il ya
plus d'habitants donc le dépouillement
est plus long mais tout à l'heure on a
eu les résultats war et au havre on
s'est rendu compte que jean luc
mélenchon est arrivé en tête alors que
c'est la ville où edouard philippe et
mer ce n'est pas emmanuel macron qui a
gagné au havre est ce qu'on a le
résultat amenons à meudon toujours pas
alors adrien appliquez-vous là il vous
plaît parce que parce qu on a les
internautes de la grande soirée qui nous
suivent ils vont se dire il ne trouve
rien ces deux là elle est une petite
ville mais j'en cherchais nous avons
kimi kevin qui nous demandent les
résultats à maulévrier m à huer le vert
vr pardon hiver maulévrier aucun 9
exactement maulévrier dans le maine et
loire exactement emmanuel macron voyez
qu'on peut trouver des résultats assez
largement en tête je pense que c'est
quasiment le meilleur score qu'on a vu
depuis le début dans une dans une
commune tu sais pas une toute petite
commune vous le voyez
3190 habitants ici à maulévrier emmanuel
macron est donc en tête puissante voix
assez largement devant marine le pen
petit score jean luc mélenchon par
rapport à son niveau national et c'est
yannick jadot qui est devant valérie
pécresse et devant eric zemmour surtout
faible score pour lui pour 7 pour cette
commune de maulévrier et c'est nathalie
arthaud qui en dernière position avec
seulement treize voix et lorsqu on peut
voir aussi sur les communes c'est
l'abstention et on a bien voté à un
mollet vrai dans le même année noire
parce que l'abstention est à 21,36 plus
bas qu'au niveau national on remercie
kevin kevin est ce qui nous a pas déjà
demandé kevin choix qui les attendait
une première a effectivement on embrasse
et qu'il continue un parce que nous on
veut bien l'aider à trouver les
résultats dans les communes qui lui sont
chers salle où il habite celle de ses
grands parents celle de sa famille non
on vous aide alors j'ai beaucoup de
grosses villes donc il va falloir
remonter un petit peu dit
nous avons avons nous fait mme
marie-christine nous demande banteux lui
bonto l'ua dans 95 banque l'ubs et à nt
il ya un h comme ça exactement
l'entrevue dans le 95 oui on peut pas
imaginer il ya comme 36000 communes en
france on peut pas toutes les connaître
on a révisé avec thibaut mais
vous savez combien il ya d'habitants à
banteux lui 151 alors je suis sûr que
les habitants de banteux lui nous
pardonneront de ne pas connaître ce
petit village c'est marine le pen qui
arrivait en tête avec 25 voix 28 points
74 % devant jean-luc mélenchon devant
emmanuel macron seulement troisième dans
cette commune eric zemmour score correct
avec 9 voix c'est vrai il faut toujours
il faut toujours voir le nombre
d'habitants valérie pécresse jean
lassalle dupont aignan est alors souvent
dans ces communes il ya des candidats
qui n'ont pas de voix c'est le cas de
nathalie arthaud c'est le cas d'anne
hidalgo qui n'ont pas de voix et on a
bien voté en a vingt très bonnes et il
ya seulement seize personnes trouvaient
les dans votre commune parce que vous
pouvez savoir qui c'est dans une petite
commune comme ça qui ne sont pas allés
voter 15,38 % d'abstention dans cette
commune du val d'oise banque lui donc
j'ai envie quand même d'aller voir où
s'est excusé moi je sais je sais mais
comment s'appelle c'est marie-christine
je prend exactement mme anne marie
christine qui habite à banteux lui alors
on regarde dans le val d'oise ont des
zooms un peu oui on est on est ici
regardez banteux lui le val d'oise on
est au nord ouest de paris c'est tout
petit un petit village bentot lui ça a
l'air super bon on a même des photos
magnifiques de banteux lui les verts
d'avoir une petite chapelle très sympa à
banteux lui on ira faire un tour ça vous
dit non vous n'avez pas l'air emballé
signaler les antalgiques raison que j'ai
compris ce qu'eux sinon marie-christine
va me le rocher dans le chat et voilà il
sait pas du tout ce qu'on veut alors je
vois beaucoup de grandes communes allez
on en est c'est là on va essayons
essayons est-ce qu'on est une commune en
a eu le va avant tout à l'heure j'y
crois pas si vous avez des petites
communes je prends aussi
donc moi je dois père et je suis pas sûr
est-ce qu'on a trois est-ce qu'on a
trois à les ententes entente 3 c'est
pour amin bien sûr la ville de françois
baroin est ce qu on a trois oui on a
trois voyez vous êtes mauvaises langues
27,8 0 8% des voix pour emmanuel macron
5466 voix à 3 devant jean-luc mélenchon
devant marine le pen seulement troisième
dans cette commune eric zemmour est en
quatrième position valérie pécresse 5e
score faible aussi comme partout en
france évidemment mais vous voyez que
même si le maire par exemple d'une
grande ville et d'une tendance politique
on voit que ça se caractérise pas
forcément au niveau national même si
emmanuel macron est en tête qu'on sait
les la proximité parfois idéologique
entre les républicains et la république
en marche on va descendre doucement
yannick jadot nicolas dupont aignan
fabien roussel qui arrive dernier
nathalie arthaud et on a très mal voté à
trois regards des 32 30 l'une ensuite 45
% d'abstention mauvais élèves pour
l'instant je suis pas je pense qu'à des
mois c'est presque le sait presque le le
moins bon score en terme de
participation depuis qu'on a commencé ce
live est ce qu on a autre chose adrien
oui nous avons alors on a un code postal
à l'espace alors marcher avec le corps
essayer ces doudous donc l'acceptation à
doudou 80 580 est ce qu'on va voir
important les 12 - combien 85 181,85 180
est-ce qu'on a ça alors j'ai
l'impression que c'est château-d'olonne
château d'olonne 85 180 vous voyez ça
fonctionne aussi avec le code postal
vous pouvez aller sur le site du figaro
vous trouvez la page des résultats elle
arrive très très haut sur la page
d'accueil et ensuite vous tapez le nom
alors non on n'a pas les résultats on
n'a pas encore les résultats dans dans
cette commune malheureusement est ce qu
on a les résultats de 2010 est dans
cette commune oui
alors est ce qu'on les a oui regardez
c'était françois fillon qui était arrivé
en tête à l'époque 30,53 % des voix pour
l'instant n'a pas les résultats
château-d'olonne mes doudous déjà il ya
un très joli pseudo dont il revient
quand il veut on s'en souvient et en
charge tout à l'heure le résultat de
château d'olonne c'est en vendée sachez
le nom charade rien nous allons
retourner sur le site on va prendre le
commentaire de luca oui a expliqué à
expliquer parce que il ya des gens qui
me suivent sur youtube on peut demander
partout et je vois voilà plusieurs
personnes qui sur youtube notamment nous
disent ouais ou est-ce qu'on peut
commenter est-ce que c'est sur le site
du figaro on est en live à la fois sur
le site internet du figaro.fr sur
youtube et sur facebook donc nous on
thibault et moi on voit les les les
trois les trois chat donc pourrait
demander
les résultats dans vos communes où vous
le voulez moi donc nous et lucas nous
demande les résultats
les vents à l'évent alors que ces
espaces vns dans le 07 à l es ah oui
d'accord c'est en deux fois c'est pas
les vents comme ça ouais il accord
immédiatement c'est en ardèche les vents
alors les vents et bien c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui est arrivé en tête à
imagine qu'on dit au vent du coup on dit
oh non je m'en ont dit le mât comment il
va pouvoir répondre dans le tibet wii pc
quand on part normalement on dit et je
vais au mans par exemple donc je vais au
vent bon alors lui nous dit les
résultats de l'évent bon de l'est
est pareil si lui qui va nous dire
comment on appelle les habitants de
l'évent les valeurs les vallées vengea
jeu c'est pas bon jean luc mélenchon
premier 33% des voix ça c'est un très
bon score pour lui emmanuel macron et 2e
marine le pen est troisième eric zemmour
arrive ensuite devant valérie pécresse
dans cette commune valérie pécresse
alors en gros stress les frais de
campagne 5,36 % des voix avec 90 bois et
nick shadow vient ensuite on continue de
descendre jean lassalle fabien roussel
anne hidalgo nicolas dupont aignan
nathalie arthaud philippe poutou et 23%
que par d'abstention à aller vent s'est
pas trop mal c'est pas trop mal on
félicite les habitants de l'évent dans
l'ardèche avoir lâché un nom de commune
très long alors allez-y thibault va
jouer alors aux questions de donc qu'une
yao qui nous demandent à l'êta à saint
sauveur de landemont alors d'essence
over je suis persuadé qu'il y en a
beaucoup moins d'essence over regard des
sainsois oui et c'est ça le problème il
faut savoir c'est deux landais mont et
ouais mais alors j'ai pas et c'est dans
49 abbas et ça je peux trouver peut-être
regarder ah non j'ai passé 5
2 alors long débat voilà c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça suffisait devient un
paquet de communes qui s'appelle saint
sauveur vous avez vu saint sauveur de
landemont donc dans le maine et loire
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on a une
commune du maine-et-loire qui prend la
tête des demandes dans notre dans notre
dans notre chatte malheureusement pas de
résultats on n'a pas le résultat
malheureusement à saint sauveur de
landemont mais on promet à chaque fois
alors présidentielle 2022 dans la
période résultat alors fut très étonné
riant n'y a pas de résultats en 2017
alors peut-être que c'est une toute
petite commune qui des fois bon on
suivra ce a expliqué nous peut-être
pourquoi on a pas on n'a pas 2012 sachez
qu'en 2000 ou non pourtant regardez
ouais mais on a quand même des résultats
en 2012 c'est nicolas sarkozy qui table
on peut remonter loin on peut remonter à
plusieurs années qui est arrivé en tête
devant françois hollande et françois
hubert où on a l'impression que c'est
une autre époque c'était il ya dix ans
est-ce qu'on a une autre commune adrien
nous avons roche fourche à c'est encore
un kevin qui nous demande sur trois
jours challans le dans le top 6 et
latéraux évidemment le 26 on a des
résultats ah oui alors là ça y est on
tient le record pour l'instant regarder
le nombre de voix café marine le pen 4
voit ici avec 57,14 % des voix et que
trois candidats quand il ôte des voix il
ya eu sept votants emmanuel macron
valérie pécresse alors attendez je note
pour l'instant à celui iphone guen je
note alors combien on a d'habitants est
ce qu on le sait malheureusement n'ont
dénombré un seul habitant en 2018 alors
excuse moi excusez moi mais en 2018 en
avait quatre salles habitants donc soit
on a bourré les urnes soit à un rush
fourche à on à remplumer un peu la
commune il ya de nouveaux habitants je
note j'ai incarné je vous ai dit rush
fourche a pour l'instant recorman de la
plus petite commune qu'on ait eu à
chercher depuis le début rouge pour
chats dans la drôme fait mieux si vous
arrivez à trouver plus ouailles on prend
ça va être compliqué mais on est encore
avec vous pendant pendant plus d'une
heure donc vous aimez ouais on va
forcément nuire aux fourches à je note
dans la drôme sept votants voilà c'est
le plus le plus petit nombre de votants
alors je peux même me regarder savoir
l'abstention il ya une personne qui
s'est abstenu à rochefort chat vous le
voyez ici ce qui donne 12,55 ce n'est
sans doute pas kevin nom ait alors ce
qui est bien c'est que cela veut dire
qu'ils prennent aussi la tête à
rochechouart chat de la plus faible
abstention 2 50% des voix une personne
qui s'est abstenu dans cette commune est
ce qu'on a autre chose ailleurs dit moi
tout alors un drive
là vous êtes beaucoup plus nombreux donc
on va on va prendre par exemple
[Musique]
meyreuil meyreuil est ce que vous faites
un choix pour une raison quelconque il
ya des gamins que je vous jure sens que
vous cherchez vous avez envie à des gens
que vous avez pas envie de suivre à mort
mais on va prendre tout le monde quand
tout le monde c'est colette qui nous
demandent ça sur facebook le fmi y est
on y est mais y élève à regarder j'ai un
autre merveille mais qui s'écrit pas
pareil dans les hautes-alpes dans le sol
et m e y y r e j magie noire exactement
juillet
et bien voilà donc il ya plusieurs
orthographes à meyreuil dans les
bouches-du-rhône donc commune de
5796 habitants en 2018 malheureusement
n'a pas le résultat encore à mes
résultats mettons à regarder
présidentielle 2017 ça avait été serré
au deuxième tour un vous voyez à peine
52 au deuxième tour on se projette
passer la semaine prochaine on refera ça
mais à l'époque au premier tour c'est
marine le pen qui était déjà arrivé en
tête fait de très bons scores dans les
bouches du rhône françois fillon était
deuxième emmanuel macron était 3e jean
luc mélenchon était 4e à l'époque mais
on recherchera vous revenez tout à
l'heure et on cherchera à meyreuil alors
j'ai envie de chercher meyreuil quand
même dans les hautes-alpes parce que
j'ai vu une chercheuse meyreuil j'ai
alors commencé comment j'ai écrit ça
tout à l'heure hop je crois que c'était
comme ça
je trouve ah si je le retrouve pour
savoir la différence entre meyreuil et
meyreuil sachets caméras et des
hautes-alpes c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui arrive en tête avec 15 voix 19
points 74 % des électeurs ont voté pour
lui une voie pour anne hidalgo qui
arrive dernière dans cette commune une
très bonne participation seulement 13 %
d'abstention vous le voyez ici allez
j'arrête de le faire mais petite
recherche on suit ce que nous disent les
gens sur les réseaux sociaux mais à leur
ordre
allez on va prendre le dernier
commentaire celui de gonzague qui nous
demandaient un soldat dont soir à saint
julien assange julien pardon de josy
saint-julien alors là je suis sûr qu'il
y en a beaucoup des seins je viens vous
les voyez apparaître ou aussi dans ma
liste saint julien 2 de josy j ong y
cédant 2,61 je n'ai rien dit on à toutes
les communes de france vous pouvez le
faire chez vous vous allez sur la page
d'accueil du figaro vous trouvez ce qui
ce cette page où vous tapez votre
résultat si malheureusement on n'arrive
pas à vous répondre à saint julien de
josy donc 3 146 habitants petite commune
est malheureusement là non plus on n'a
pas encore les résultats dans cette dans
cette commune de saint julien de josy
ces particuliers envoient y en a eu tout
à l'heure les résultats award ça dépend
des fois expliquez-nous comment ça
marche comment on arrive à voir les
scores aussi vite alors on a
des personnes aux services data au
figaro au deuxième étage qui reçoivent
les résultats donc du ministère de
l'intérieur qu'il est rentré en direct
pour que pour qu'on les ait le plus
rapidement possible et on sait rentrée
donc saint-julien donzy malheureusement
soient les résultats n'ont pas été
transmis tout de suite il n'y a pas de
problèmes techniques ça arrive très vite
c'est vrai tout à l'heure on a eu la
plus grande ville qu'on a eu pour
l'instant c'est le havre et on rappelle
que les grandes villes c'est plus
compliqué parce que soient les bureaux
de vote ont fermé plus tard soit le
dépouillement est évidemment plus l'on
dit moi une autre ville adrien alors sur
le site nous avons janyk qui nous
demandent des résultats à ploemeur alors
lorsque l'homme de ploemeur pl au 1e à
oui d'accord
mais alors ploemeur c'est en bretagne
que j'avais exactement ça un nom à
consonance bretonne ploner on connaît un
petit peu dit 7790 habitants c'est bien
ça on a le résultat ap le maire emmanuel
macron très bon score 37 32 % des voix
et derrière ça tombe tout de suite
marine le pen à peine plus que jean luc
mélenchon 2120 voix contre 2023 voix
c'est yannick jadot qui fait un bon
score à la demeure c'est vrai la gauche
s'est plutôt bien représenté 1
finalement jean luc mélenchon yannick
jadot et derrière ça tombe évidemment un
peuple un peu plus bas anne hidalgo de
nicolas dupont aignan philippe poutou je
défile jusqu'en basse et nathalie
arthaud qui en dernière position on a
bien voté à ploemeur l'abstention est de
85% dans cette commune du morbihan
toujours sur le site thibault nous avons
jean-rené il qu'ils nous demandent les
résultats à dinard alors jean rené adina
art dinars c'est une grande ville aussi
dinars est-ce qu'on va afin grandes
villes plus grandes villes que ce qu'on
a pu voir récemment dit 1148 habitants
et on a les résultats dinars bien jouer
adrien bien jouer jean rené emmanuel
macron très bons scores à dinard ah oui
bel écart prévu
38,95 % pour le pour le
président-candidat marine le pen et 2e
jean luc mélenchon est troisième mais un
score assez assez faible quoi qu un aux
alentours de celui de marine le pen est
presque plus proche c'est marine le pen
qui s'effondre le plus dans kiss et font
comment dire tu es le moins bon score
par rapport à son niveau national c'est
ça qu'on essaie de comparer eric zemmour
9,59 valérie pécresse yannick jadot
alors j'aimerais bien comparer parce que
ça c'est bon on peut le faire et c'est
intéressant on note vous souvenez adrien
38 95% pour emmanuel macron 15 29 pour
marine le pen 14 39 pour jean luc
mélenchon aller voir ce qu'ils s'étaient
alors voir ce qui s'est passé en 2010
est dans cette commune au premier tour
c'est françois fillon si j'étais arrivé
en tête voyez donc emmanuel macron a
peut-être récupérer certaines des voix
de françois fillon il a bien progressé
et marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
sont à peu près au même score en je
crois qu'il est à 15,16 là il soit très
et 12 voilà pour ce qu'on peut voir on
peut comparer vous pouvez le faire vous
pouvez allez voir vous pouvez me
remonter plus loin alors que l'on n'a
plus les mêmes candidats évidemment mais
vous pouvez trouver les scores de
françois hollande de nicolas sarkozy il
ya dix ans dites moi on a autre chose
rires oui allez on repart sur facebook
stéphane nous demande les résultats à
saint pierre en faucigny à saint pierre
en faucigny je connais de nom mais alors
je connais parce que moi je suis de
haute-savoie pour travailler là donc je
connais saint-pierre-en-faucigny
regardez c'est le 74 dont je sais
comment l'écrire je n'embrasse tout
particulièrement stéphane on m'a dit que
vous étiez d'où vous à la base alors moi
je suis né alors voilà donc un breton et
enfin savoyard donc n'hésitez pas on va
vous favorisez surtout vous c'est pour
ça ploemeur je comprends bien que vous
ayez choisi ploemeur a donc
saint-pierre-en-faucigny en haute savoie
marine le pen 28% ciel qui est en tête
devant emmanuel macron devant jean-luc
mélenchon eric zemmour est à 7 37% des
voix on a un score qui est plutôt en
accord avec le niveau national
même si emmanuel macron et derrière
marine le pen mais en termes de
pourcentage de voir on est dans cet
ordre d'idée on descend parce qu'on veut
voir ce qu'on fait tous les résultats si
par exemple stéphane à voter pour
nathalie arthaud et bien il sait que
quinze autres personnes ont voté comme
lui puisque nathalie arthaud a récolté
16 voix très bon score de participation
80 pour être le meilleur volet non non
parce que tout à l'heure on est heureux
pour chats je vous rappelle roche a fait
12 % de d'abstention mais y avait sept
votants et un seul un seul
abstentionnistes donc bon retour chez
eux
on va pas les compter mais c'est vrai
que c'est un très bon score pour une
ville d'une plus grande envergure que
rhj pour chats dans la drôme
nous avons pierre-yves toujours sur
facebook r ils demandent leurs couteaux
morte aux
mondiaux-2011 et de saucisses dans la
dans l'écriture vous l'avez
vous l'avez bon va essayer de réagir
nous mais c'est ce modèle tout le monde
a dans le chat borgne donc voilà les
gens sont déchaînés sachez que je serai
au point virgule de la semaine prochaine
alors emmanuel macron est en tête à
morteau avec un très bon score 33 20%
des voix jean-luc mélenchon 3 2e 18,89 %
marine le pen et troisième score plutôt
faibles par rapport aux niveaux national
valérie pécresse un peu mieux qu'au
niveau national elle au contraire 8,0 6%
on descend yannick jadot jean lassalle
nicolas dupont aignan anne hidalgo
fabien roussel philippe utp nathalie
arthaud
mauvaise participation par exemple on
fait on félicite pas les habitants de
morteau
28,19 % alors ce que je veux voir aussi
c'est que pour l'instant on n'a jamais
eu dans le top 3 quelqu'un d'autre qui
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen c'est toujours ce trio est
ce qu'on aura bon ce qui est assez
normal vous allez me dire mais on
cherche la commune où il ya une surprise
ou quelqu'un est sur le podium alors
qu'il ne l'est pas au niveau national
d'aidé nous à la trouver
thibault est ce qu'on tenterait pas à
nouveau une grande ville dire alors
j'avais vu saint-etienne plus haut c'est
très ambigu ambitieux saint-etienne mais
tentons pourquoi pas s'intéresser à
l'abri saint-etienne nos amis stéphanois
à laurière saint-etienne le bon dans le
42 il faut que je le trouve pas ce qu'il
ya des saint-etienne un peu partout mais
alors attendez je vais taper peut-être
que saint-etienne pour être sûr d'avoir
le saint-etienne le bus est là il faut
que je tape le code postal vous pouvez
faire ça aussi chez vous 42 milliards en
2010 alors pourquoi j'ai pas
saint-etienne je comprends pas je vais
chercher ça saint-etienne experts
appelés nous comment on fait pour donner
les résultats de rien comment on fait
pour demander le résultat sur le site
est bien
sur sur le sur les tchats 1 on est
d'accord vous que vous soyez sur le site
internet du figaro sur facebook ou sur
youtube on est en live sur les trois
plateformes vous nous donnez le nom de
la commune le département ça peut aider
et nous on rentre ça dans notre
sur notre site internet je vous remets
lien d'ailleurs dans le chatt puisque
vous pouvez le faire vous chez vous
également si adrien a décidé de pas vous
prendre pour une raison quelconque vous
pouvez chercher mais attendez on va
essayer de trouver ensemble pouvait même
faire découvrir votre commune au reste
des français du chat ont fait des tours
des fois sur la carte de france pour
savoir où se trouvent certaines villes
pour savoir comment s'appellent certains
habitants j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle on
n'a pas les résultats encore non mais
alors on s'y attend parce que c'est une
trop grande ville pour l'instant il ya
trop d'électeurs évidemment et donc le
des poules le dépouillement prend un peu
plus de temps dix mois plus tard dans la
soirée alors tentons greenwood sur
youtube qui nous demandent des résultats
puis enlevée en les lui en veulent et
alors ça c'est la commune de laurent
wauquiez évidemment le puy en velay
allons-y cette grande ville aux siens le
puy en velay et on n'a toujours pas les
résultats alors est ce que c'est un fief
de droite on va aller voir ce qu'il
s'est passé en 2010 est donc pas
tellement puisque c'est emmanuel macron
qu'ils aient remporté la mise c'était
très serré à l'époque on verra on ira
voir le puy-en-velay je note parce que
ça m'intéresse je note sur mon calepin
le puy-en-velay pour savoir qui est
arrivé en tête dans sept communes on a
autre chose adrien dites moi oui alors
on va tenter une plus petite commune et
on reviendra sur les sur des plus
grandes un peu plus tard commune parce
que vous ne la connaissez pas c'est ça
nous avons quentin sur facebook ils
mentent vic-en-bigorre alors vu que cvs
lissées vie comme alors là c'est pas
attaché mais j'imagine que c'est bigorre
comme ça et va on va trouver des gorges
évidemment dans les hautes pyrénées ça
sonne tout de suite comme sahin bigorre
pas de problème marine le pen est en
tête à vic en bigorre avec 778 voix
presque 30% des électeurs emmanuel
macron deuxième position jean luc
mélenchon alors sans trop de surprise de
regarder qui arrive en quatrième
position dans une région qui lui est
cher jean lassalle jean lassalle 1 234
voix devant eric zemmour devant yannick
jadot valérie pécresse fabien roussel je
défile vous arrivez à lire nathalie
arthaud dernière avec 15 voix on n'a pas
très très bien voter à vic-en-bigorre
l'abstention de 27% alors est-ce qu'on
tenterait
barbizon dans le 77 barbizon c'est pour
lise marie sur facebook lise marie
bonjour lise-marie j'espère qu'elle va
bien alors barbizon regardant ce qu'on a
dans le 77 ans nadia les résultats à
barbizon c'est emmanuel macron très bon
score du prénom de la république et
regardez on se demander s'il y aurait
des communes où le top 3 ne serait pas
trop ce tte par emmanuel macron marine
le pen et jean luc mélenchon ça il y en
a une à barbizon c'est eric zemmour qui
arrive en deuxième position
184 voix avec 18 42% c'est un très bon
score alors c'est vrai que c'est une
petite commune mais il arrive quand même
en deuxième position devant marine le
pen devant jean-luc mélenchon et
regarder valérie pécresse qui fait un
très bon score également c'est peut-être
que dans cette commune les voix de la
droite se sont dispersés très bon score
c'est relatif mais très bon score par
rapport à son niveau national yannick
jadot et puis derrière ça tombe
évidemment un est ce que tout le monde a
eu des voix oui philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud ont eu des voix aussi 4
voir on a bien voté on a bien voté à
barbizon presque 20 % d'abstention un
peu moins c'est bien alors on nous
reproche de rester dans la métropole
dont repartir dans les dom on va faire
le nombre nous misons raison qu'ils ont
raison c'est les gosiers 90 790 allons-y
le gosier combien qui est en tête au
gosier en guadeloupe
c'est jean luc mélenchon et regardez ce
sera largement il aurait été lui au
premier tour si on avait voté seulement
à gosier
51,67 % des voix prescrire mais il a
gagné dans quasiment alors on regardera
les départements ce sera plus dur de les
regarder vous nous rappeler regret
pourquoi mais jean-luc mélenchon a fait
des très bons scores dans l'est dans les
dom-tom presque 50% dans quasiment
quatre cibles et les les outre mer c'est
compliqué les départements de les avoir
tout de suite expliquez nous pourquoi de
rien pour ceux qui nous rejoignent parce
qu'il nous faut absolument
enfin toutes les communes fin les
résultats de toutes les communes pour
pouvoir les afficher donc
voilà on le rappelle les grandes villes
ça viendra un peu plus tard dans la
soirée donc c'est pour ça que voilà
jusqu'ici vous avez beaucoup de
résultats de petites communes mais on
pourra on pourra tenter certaines
régions enfin toutes les régions mais
certains départements on ne peut plus
tard un peu plus tard dans la soirée
voilà et séverine nous remercient elle
nous dit merci pour les dom en bon alors
et regardez regardez aussi ça c'est
important
l'abstention dans les dom tom au gosier
52 % d'abstention j'ai fait défiler la
liste pour vous puissiez voir
complètement les résultats au gosier
abstention très élevé c'est quasiment
l'endroit où on a le moins de bien voter
depuis le début de ce live depuis qu'on
cherche
point noir au gosier aller ses cartons
carton jaune
alors nous avons cugnaux qui nous avait
demandé saint sauveur de landemont tout
à l'heure vu que ça n'a pas fonctionné
il peut tenter champtoceaux alors oui
mais ils nous donnent des villes aussi
qu'on connaît pas on va les chercher où
c'est alors dites moi comment ça s'écrit
alors ça s'écrit ch amp amp t au
cea 8 je le vois c'est ici champ alors
changez vos sauts chance thomas je sais
pas il peut nous dire la prononcer en
totale prononce cugnaux sur youtube il
va pouvoir nous répondre seize mille
habitants et on a le résultat net a
soutenu à la fin ça déjà on peut le
satisfaire là dessus presque 34 % des
voix pour emmanuel macron très bons
scores marine le pen
24,19 jean luc mélenchon 17% un peu plus
bas que son niveau national janyk jadot
est en quatrième position ici devant
eric zemmour valérie pécresse jean
lassalle nicolas dupont aignan est
toujours ceux qui ferment la marche anne
hidalgo fabien roussel philippe poutou
et nathalie arthaud on a bien participé
presque 78 % une abstention à 22 33 % à
champtoceaux j'ai envie d'aller
récompensé c'est kevin c'est ça la sécu
nyayo à cugnaux alors qu'une yayo
regarder on peut voir aussi on essaie de
chercher on révise notre géographie à
champoz saut je cherche je pense que
c'est ici on voit si je vais dézoomer
pour qu'on puisse voir où on est
exactement r&d en et près de nantes on
est tout près de nantes ici on n'est pas
très loin de la mer à champoz saut et je
vous montre même une petite photo la
commune s'avère très beau champeau so et
beznau sera plus réellement pourquoi pas
dit nous on veut la plus belle commune
on va aller en chercher quelques unes
epyon on notera trompeuse soit la palme
pour l'instant dit moi on a d'autres
personnes qui cherchent d'autres
résultats chez eux oui on a marins sur
facebook qui nous demandent les
résultats de rambouillet dans le 78 à
rambouillet ces grands rambouillet
amassé assez grand alors tant d'autres
attentats ont embrouillé non non on n'a
pas les résultats rambouillet c'est un
peu trop grand 26 1933 habitants le
dépouillement est toujours plus long
dans ce genre de communes revenez on
recherchera rambouillet pour notre ami
qui nous suit sur le réseau dites-moi
son nom vous en souvenez vous avez marre
un marin c'est ça marrant on cherche
pour vous un peu plus tard
nous avons mademoiselle martin qui a vu
les résultats dans les dom et donc qui
nous demander s'il est possible d'avoir
les résultats pour les français de
l'étranger et qui nous demande denver je
sais pas je ne sais pas si je sais pas
si je vais revoir on va essayer je suis
pas sûr un denver n'ont sans doute pas
et on va se renseigner parce que ça fait
intéressant pour savoir comment on peut
on peut essayer de trouver les résultats
des français de l'étranger on va envoyer
un petit message aux personnes qui
s'occupent de ça je vous le laisse le
faire adrien tant que je m'intéresse de
savoir si on a une possibilité nous
alors là on est sur nos conversations si
on a une convertie une possibilité nous
de trouver les résultats les résultats
dans d'autres d'autres pays avec les
résultats parlant d'un bureau de vote je
sais pas au québec par exemple à dender
surtout danser dans ces pays dames et
dans ces pays d'amérique du nord des
résultats tombent toujours un peu plus
tôt évidemment on va essayer de trouver
la réponse et on revient vers vous voilà
c'est demandé à nos collègues vont voir
ça tout de suite la plante verte sur
youtube à dieppe dans le 67 élèves
essayer de mettre un peu d'eau sur la
planche alors sur facebook c'est que des
prénoms et lennon est sûr sur youtube on
va avoir pas mal de pseudo d'accord
alors une pareille on peut faire un
concours du point ce dôme est là pour
l'instant c'est la place verte c'est
inouï non non la plante verte c'est
super j'espère que la plante verte s'est
déplacé quand même pour aller voter mais
c'est nous demande alors sachez qu'à
dieppe regarder on a les résultats en
seine maritime marine le pen est en tête
78 % des voix devant emmanuel macron
découdre c'est assez serré en effet jean
luc mélenchon est troisième et derrière
un peu comme à chaque fois même si on a
eu quelques surprises dans certaines
communes le trou et eric zemmour avec 5%
des voix 7 133 voix fabien roussel fait
un score honorable dans cette commune
4,95 judas à régler moore puis on
descend yannick jadot valérie pécresse
dans la salle c'est philippe poutou qui
est dernier dans cette ville avec 103
voix on n'a pas forcément très bien
voter à dieppe 30 % d'abstention on a
sur le site aussi on a des pseudos on va
prendre celui de 4 à strophes
ah oui c'est bien donc on imagine que
c'est catherine catastrophe non mais
c'est écrit c'est kristen mann a donc 4
à strophes d'accord donc là on a un bon
cours de pseudo entre entre les guitares
vertes et catastrophes et le site alors
essayons de donner une bonne nouvelle la
catastrophe voilà donc elles demandent
des résultats au le sable de 24500
sables d'olonne évidemment c'est en
vendée là d'où part le vendée globe
évidemment les sables d'olonne
catastrophe continue on n'a toujours pas
le résultat je vous rappelle qu'on peut
regarder les anciens résultat si vous
nous rejoignez donc on peut comparer on
va comparer même si on n'a pas encore
tout à fait les résultats on va regarder
c'était françois fillon qui est arrivé
en tête à l'époque devant emmanuel
macron marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon n'hésitez pas un peu plus tard
dans la soirée vous nous reposer la
question où vous cherchez vous même sur
ce site sur sept pages du figaro vous
allez sur la page d'accueil très vite
vous allez trouver cette page de
résultats vous tapez le nom de votre
commune de la commune de vos
grands-parents ou de vos amis que
sais-je et vous trouvez des résultats si
vous les avez pas tout de suite vous
revenez un peu plus tard et vous les
aurez et vous pouvez même vous inscrire
sur le site c'est pourtant sur le figaro
c'est vrai que il faut le dire vous
pouvez vous inscrire donc en
téléchargeant l'application du figaro
vous entraînons de votre commune et dès
que les résultats sont disponibles on
vous les envois vous recevez une petite
notification sur votre sur votre
téléphone
donc voilà ça peut arriver beaucoup plus
tard dans la soirée surtout pour les
grosses villes donc n'hésitez pas à le
faire allons-y on passe sur cette page
vous ayez un peu à l'antenne pour que
les gens voient qui parle c'est parfait
bon
alors aurélien sur youtube là on a des
recettes au classique sobre efficace
aurélien dites-nous bazas b à z as dans
le 33 regardez ça sort tout de suite
bazas commune de 4780 18 habitants en
2018 on descend et on a le résultat à
bazas emmanuel macron 28% alors là aussi
on colle au niveau national à peu près 1
je veux dire par rapport à l'écart le
pourcentage est jamais tout à fait
parfait mais emmanuel macron est en tête
devant marine le pen devant jean-luc
mélenchon eric zemmour et 3e jean
lassalle très bon score de jean lassalle
qui fait une toute petite voix de moins
qu eric zemmour on le voit ici valérie
pécresse yannick jadot anne hidalgo etc
etc on descend je défile neuf voix
seulement pour arrêter les retourne à
bien voter à bazas en gironde
20,81 % je vous dis aussi que si par
exemple vous cliquez sur le nom d'un
candidat là vous avez toutes les
informations sur lui son programme vous
pouvez vous renseigner bon le premier
tour est passé le programme de philippe
poutou c'est trop tard mais si vous
voulez par exemple connaître le
programme de marine le pen ou d'emmanuel
macron ça peut encore servir pour le
second tour on les a remontés sur le
site dont vous allez trouver très
facilement
alors on retourne sur facebook nous
avons martin qui nous demandent les
résultats de lille us elle y eut h par
non us elle alors re dit moi l us elle y
hsl alors lis us dans le 60 exactement
c'est loiseleux 60
petites communes 416 habitants donc on
devrait avoir le résultat suspense oui
on a le résultat marine le pen 50 78 %
des voix en métropole je crois que c'est
le plus haut score qu'on est qu'on ait
vu pour l'instant pour 3 candidat dans
une candidat ou une candidate il est
selon jean marie bergeret entre des
positions aussi c'est ça jean luc
mélenchon 3e éric zemmour dans une
commune comme ça il est possible que
certains candidats n'est pas de voix
c'est le cas par exemple ici nord tout
le monde a une voix dernière anne
hidalgo elle a eu une petite voix dans
cette commune le liffe us voilà dit moi
on a autre chose oui nous avons alors
alors il faut que je cherche un peu
cherchez prenez votre temps prenez votre
temps et on salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent alors précisément on est en
direct il est 22 heures 46 c'est très
simple ici ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
vous donne les résultats dans votre
commune vous tapez le nom de votre
commune qui vous voulez une commune qui
vous intéressent adrien me la transmet
et moi je la cherche sur le site du
figaro.fr sur le site sur la page
d'accueil vous avez la même page que moi
vous pouvez le faire vous même mais ici
on s'amuse on essaye de trouver on
révise un peu notre géographie a dream
transmet et on trouve les résultats
comme on vient de le faire à lille où
marine le pen a fait un excellent score
52 78 % des voix c'est toujours
intéressant je suis sûr que les
candidats regarde très précisément ce
qui se passe dans ces communes pour
savoir notamment où mettre les
principaux candidats pour les
législatives qui arrive derrière ça
c'est intéressant dites moi donc que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut chercher parce
qu'ils font
on va aider alexandra trouver les
résultats dans la commune de saint
macaire saint macaire ça veut dire que
macaire est un prénom j'imagine
puisqu'il a un sens ouais connaissent us
que je connais aucun qui n'ont
maintenant plus bas si on peut demander
ce qu'il ya des gens sur le chat qui
s'appelle macaire arnaquer ils seront
prioritaires pour la prochaine ville
saint macaire donc en gironde également
deuxième fois de suite attention vous
faites du favori si jean luc mélenchon
est donc en tête à saint macaire en
gironde 292 voix devant emmanuel macron
marine le pen eric zemmour avec un peu
plus haut que au niveau national jean
lassalle qui fait visiblement une un bon
score 1 pour lui jean lassalle 5 83%
yannick jadot valérie pécresse fabien
roussel anne hidalgo nicolas dupont
aignan c'est nathalie arthaud qui ferme
la marche juste après philippe poutou
abstention dans la moyenne nationale
24,46 % à saint-macaire thibault je vous
propose de partir dans le var ah mais ça
nous demande des rubalises arts de saint
maximin à saint maximin alors saint
maximin c'est très joli saint maximin
dans le var et je sais pourquoi je l'est
pas enfin j'ai pas le saint maximin du
var en tout cas
60 entre abc pour ça parce que le nom
complet c'est saint maximin la sainte
baume de ne pas apprécier suis pas
content
j'aurais pu préciser c'est vrai on n'a
pas les résultats malheureusement encore
à saint maximin c'est très joli saint
maximin malheureusement on n'a pas les
résultats et je vous rappelle que si ça
arrive les résultats vous nous
redemander un peu plus tard où vous
revenez chercher sur ce site où vous
laissez votre mail et on vous les envois
c'est ça on s'inscrit sur le site
exactement - sur l'aigle sur
l'application
alors on a une réponse pour les français
de l'étranger a dit moi alors je vous
rappelle si vous nous rejoignez tout à
l'heure on nous demandait si on pouvait
avoir les résultats des français de
l'étranger parce qu'ici on n'a que les
communes métropole et d'outre-mer mais
on n'arrive pas on n'arrivait pas pour
l'instant avoir les résultats à
l'étranger des français de l'étranger
dit moi alors ils sont pas encore
présents dans le moteur de recherche
d'ailleurs en faisant une recherche sur
le site internet le service politique du
figaro a fait des articles dessus donc
vous pourrez les vous pourrez les
trouver d'accord donc si on va sur le
site du figaro on tape les français de
l'étranger le figaro et on va avoir des
résultats malheureusement ils sont pas
dans cette base de données du ministère
de l'intérieur rappelle que ce sont tous
ces chiffres sont un cadre du ministère
de l'intérieur qui nous sont envoyées
alors on va remonter un peu qu'est ce
qu'on a ici et moi vous êtes sur
facebook sur youtube alors le jeu di
rupo address book on a une commune qui
s'appelle glandage landaise oui c'est le
nom d'une commune oui exactement
d'accord mais du coup c'est marrant
quand même langage c'est pour ça que
l'aggraver puisque vue parfaite le point
virgule dans
le grand âge c'est parce qu'on fait ici
ce soir je voudrais tout de suite parce
que on vous aide recherche les communes
alors à glandage dans la drôme
figurez-vous il est à 118 habitants et
c'est donc jean luc mélenchon qui est le
roi des glandeurs c'est jose disant non
je sais pas alors comment on appelle les
habitants de glandage ça ça m'intéresse
là il faut qu'on trouve un leurre
glandage on est obligé de chercher alors
déjà dans les meilleurs temps de
communes jusqu'ici on a fait plusieurs
tonneaux wade il enverra jean-louis
glandage c'est pas mal du tout alors je
cherche puisque mon cher joyon s'est mis
cette petite carte pour trouver les
communes alors glandage c'est ici dans
la drôme de voiliers et donc je vais
chercher je vais sur cette petite page
wikipédia qui est notre ami et donc les
habitants de glandage ce sont les
glandes ajoie et les glandage oise
je vois là oui on a eu chaud c'est vrai
que votre esprit mal placé donc la
glande âge on rappelle que c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui est en tête devant
devant je regarde je remonte devant
marine le pen emmanuel macron jean
lassalle qui fait un bon score avec
blindage eric zemmour assez faible en
dalles seulement deux voix et nathalie
arthaud et anne hidalgo n'ont décroché
aucun suffrage dans cette commune
glandage je le note record pour
l'instant de faire un record en tout cas
on le met dans notre classement de la
ville la plus drôle je vous rappelle que
ces roches fourche a pour l'instant dans
la drôme également la drôme qui trustent
les premières places d'un classement qui
est la plus petite commune avec
seulement sept votants un
abstentionniste
est-ce qu'on a autre chose adrien notre
ville oui on va alors on va regarder du
côté de youtube qu'est-ce qu'on a du
côté de youtube nous avons alors je
l'avais juste ici kamel qui nous
demandent qu'une ré dans le morbihan
alors dites moi ah oui c'est vrai vous
favorisez les bretons oui j'ai alors
comment ça s'écrit pl us ert
minerai pluneret dans le morbihan donc
je tape le nom dans le moteur de
recherche je descends je vois le nombre
d'habitants
5796 habitants et dans cette commune
s'est donc emmanuel macron qui arrive en
tête 33 points 96 % des suffrages devant
marine le pen juste devant mélenchon
assez serré dans cette commune du
morbihan de plus ne rêve yannick jadot
et quatrième on se rend compte que
yannick jadot fait des scores un peu
meilleure en bretagne depuis tout à
l'heure on a eu souvent le souvent le
cas eric zemmour valérie pécresse fabien
roussel je descends jean lassalle et
c'est nathalie arthaud qui ferme la
marche on a bien voté à punir et puisque
je vous rappelle qu'on peut voir
l'abstention également abstention 20%
veut me voir les votes blancs et les
votes nuls danser dans ces communes là
on a autre chose on a autre chose à
matisse artistique samedi c'est pas
important je peux vous le dire des
graines saint-mars m ars ce qui va
sortir tout de suite non des graines egr
unha-2 tout attaché d'air
des comme ça
alors apostrophe des apostats oui
d'accord aussi jose à des élevages mère
je sais exactement là bas quand vous
êtes clair voilà si vous n'êtes pas
simple mais j'ai une confiance absolue
dans votre jugement et votre capacité à
me transmettre les bonnes informations
du life et donc à saint mars d'egrenne
dans l'orne c'est emmanuel macron qui
arrive en tête avec un très bon score
39,22 % des voix devant marine le pen
devant jean-luc mélenchon et valérie
pécresse et est quatrième ici dans cette
dans cette commune de l'orne de saint
mars d'egrenne eric zemmour nicolas
dupont aignan et je vais aller en bas
comme à chaque fois parce que si par
exemple qui nous a demandé ça c'est
martin je crois non vous le dites qui
sait mathis fin voilà mathis est vrai
mathis par exemple si c'est la seule
personne à avoir voté ni algo il a
besoin de savoir si c'est le seul à
avoir donné sa voix à la candidate du
parti socialiste celle qui ferme la
marche avec seulement un suffrage dans
cette commune de l'orne alors on avait
marin qui nous demandaient rambouillet
tout à l'heure ils nous demandent rouen
alors si on n'a pas eu les résultats en
bouyer a priori on va te mettre à douter
oui je vous savez quoi je vais tenter
par ce qu on rappelle que la plus grande
ville qu'on a réussi dans laquelle on a
réussi à trouver les résultats c'est le
avant tout à l'heure mais déjà il faut
que de l'écrire correctement rouen ça va
c'est mieux et donc rouen en
seine-maritime on n'a évidemment pas
encore les résultats on va chercher les
grandes communes on peut essayer
retrouvez les grandes communes où les
résultats sont déjà tombés dites moi
alors vous
adrien cherche sur youtube le figaro.fr
sur facebook vous pouvez commenter ou
vous voulez hein c'est ça exactement oui
sur youtube
sofia nous demandent des résultats à
chambly à chambly avec un y parfaitement
bien sûr chamby on cherche son bi
chambly dans l'oise aussi souvent dans
l'oise et bien on a des résultats à
chambly et c'est marine le pen et eric
il tentait de 29 63% des voix 25 25 pour
jean luc mélenchon emmanuel macron il
est mal passée c'est rare c'est à
seraing et ce troisième entre zéro et
c'est rare que c'est lui qui est arrivé
en tête au niveau national eric zemmour
quatrième yannick jadot valérie pécresse
fabien roussel jean lassalle nicolas
dupont aignan je descends c'est anne
hidalgo nathalie arthaud et philippe
poutou qui ferme la marche avec 37 voix
l'abstention dans cette commune
28,63 pour ça on n'a pas très bien voter
à chantepie alors je vous propose qu'on
essaye mais c'est je suis à peu près sûr
du résultat vous pouvez aussi vous
pourrez aussi surtout dans les jours à
venir probablement demain taper le nom
d'un département entier voyez comme ça
dans l'oise et vous aurez les résultats
c'est un peu trop tôt parce que adrien
rappelé le on peut pas avoir un résultat
dans l'oise pourquoi parceque il pour
les affiches et il faut avoir les
résultats de absolument toutes les
communes du département et de la région
donc donc ça sera ça sera beaucoup plus
tard exactement
alors est-ce qu'on a autre chose on vous
rappelle que vous pouvez donner le nom
de votre commune surfer sur facebook
c'est bien ça ouais sur le figaro sur
youtube où est-ce qu'on nous parle le
plus d'ailleurs alors en ce moment c'est
youtube au tout début du live c'était
plutôt facebook d'alcool on a moins de
commentaires sur le site donc
donnée sur le site parce que si vous
venez sur le site à ce moment là dessus
rioux tube par exemple vous venez sur le
site vous mettez un commentaire vous
avez plus de plus de chances qu'on le
lise parce que sur youtube y en a
beaucoup des commentaires oui alors on
avait thomas sur site qui nous
demandaient les résultats des français
et étrangers à dubaï donc on rappelle
que ils ne sont pas dans le moteur de
recherche pas encore mais en aux
journalistes politiques ont évidemment
fait des articles sur les français
l'étranger donc vous pouvez les
retrouver sur le sur le site du
figaro.fr se maintient en repartant sur
facebook allez
qu'est ce que j'ai à faire il faut que
je remonte un peu on à saint maximin on
l'a fait et je rappelle pendant qu
adrien cherche qu'on a un petit concours
ici notamment la plus petite ville pour
l'instant ces roches fourche à dans la
drôme j'ai mon carnet je note tout
proche pour chats dans la drôme
seulement sept votants est la ville la
plus rigolote au nom le plus rigolo
c'est glandage pour l'instant qu'on a eu
et qui est également dans la drôme donc
la drôme squatte le haut nos classements
fait mieux trouver la ville la plus
rigolote pour alors je prie la bâtie
neuve et évidemment sur youtube c'est il
fallait s'en douter puisqu'on a ouvert
cet arc narratif des devil au hollywood
bowl et provoqué aussi en me donnant la
ville de glandage c'est forcément envie
de jouer bon alors dites moi et donc
plusieurs internautes tout le monde les
résultats à montcuq m on a été obligé de
placer et alors vous savez quoi si on
n'avait pas eu la demande je l'aurais
chercher moi-même et alors
est-ce donc m.wen
comme ça avec un qu à la fin exactement
alors c'est dans le lot ce qu'on a les
résultats oui on les a emmanuel macron
est en tête à mon cul devant jean-luc
mélenchon devant marine le pen et devant
eric zemmour très serré avec valérie
pécresse je descends jean lassalle
yannick jadot nicolas dupont aignan
fabien roussel anne hidalgo nathalie
arthaud g grain jusqu'au bout avec
philippe poutou on a bien voté
21,47 % est ce qu'on n'irait pas
comparer à l'époque parce qu'on peut
faire ça et vous pouvez le faire vous
aussi voir il ya cinq ans comment les
habitants de mon cuir à ce que vous
savez comment s'appelle alors je n'osais
pas posé la question mais je vais aller
chercher d'abord je vais voir son joueur
ni oui vous de provoquer une fois de
plus c'est françois fillon tient je ne
fait pas de dire qui est arrivé en tête
à montcuq il y a cinq ans est donc cette
fois c'est emmanuel macron alors je vais
aller chercher déjà regardons ou c'est
parce que c'est vrai que tous les
français connaissent est cette blague et
connaissent cette cette commune
alors recreativo on est au sommet de ce
live c'est à dire à après ça ça va on va
alors nous aider je vais vous dire moi
je vais garder glandage quand même en
tête d'excellents les plus rigolotes
parce qu'on la connaît moins bon voilà
alors alors quand je voulais proposer
glandage je me suis dit est ce que c'est
vraiment un an de moi aussi je me suis
posée oui mais voilà alors vous voyez où
se trouve mon coeur un peu au nord de
de montauban et donc les habitants parce
qu'on a envie de savoir le gentillet ce
sont les mots qu cois et les mots qui
croise donc les noms qu cois éléments
cucquoise ont placé emmanuel macron en
tête dans leur commune allez on repart
un peu de sérieux c'est un peu de
sérieux on va prendre la demande de anne
marie anne marie saint c'est sur
facebook anne marie c'est sur facebook
et marie anne marie etienne du grès
saint-etienne alors on a vu qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de saint-etienne on a
cherché le saint-etienne le plus célèbre
dans la loire tout à l'heure on n'avait
pas encore les résultats du grès essaoui
débat c'est dans les bouches du rhône
comme ça me confirmer et oui
effectivement dans les bouches du rhône
alors à saint-etienne du grenelle et
résultats et comme souvent depuis le
début de ce live on se rend compte que
dans les bouches-du-rhône marine le pen
arrive en tête 31 79% des voix devant
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
les trois premiers sont aux trois
premières places même si le podium n'est
pas le même qu'au niveau national ce cas
pas dans le même ordre eric zemmour est
4e valérie pécresse jean lassalle qui à
2,15 pour s'emmener nick shadow et puis
ce sont toujours plus ou moins les mêmes
candidats qui ferme la marche c'est
philippe poutou qui récolte seulement
s'ils voient dans cette commune où on a
bien voté regard et l'abstention et on
les félicite 18,11 % des voix seulement
340 abstentionnistes sur la liste de
sainte etienne du grès
alors beaucoup plus de commentaires sur
ie sur youtube d'un coup alors peut-être
bon vous nous rejoignez bienvenue à tous
donc on va rester un peu sur youtube
allez nous félicitent les gens qui nous
suivent sur youtube on leur donne des
réponses alors nicolas bon on a pas de
pseudo là mais on y croit l'avoir gardé
un peu on va suivre ça c'est pas déjà
qu'est ce qu'on est le pseudo c'est
légal comme la plante verte pour
l'instant et 4 4 à strophes vous avez le
jeu de mots je vais le noter la plante
verte dite moi nicolas il cherche
cherche beaumont sur oise mais on n'a
pas déjà chercher ça me non sur oise
tout à l'heure
alors on a cherché beaumont mais alors
annoncé thann oui alors alors là c'est
beaumont-sur-oise beaumont sur moi c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de bons - vous le
voyez dans ma liste ici vous pouvez
aussi taper si vous êtes par exemple
habitant de beaumont sur grosne vous
pouvez trouver les résultats dans votre
commune alors beaumont-sur-oise
9555 habitants malheureusement on n'a
pas les résultats alors rappelé pourquoi
on n'a pas forcément les résultats des
grandes villes c'est vrai que des fois
on n'a pas les résultats aussi des
petites villes on se demande pourquoi on
se demande pourquoi on s'attend à avoir
faim depuis le début de la soirée
évidemment on allait on a les résultats
des petites villes beaucoup plus
rapidement simplement parce que c'est
plus facile c'est plus rapide à
dépouiller et est donc dans les grandes
villes il ya forcément plus de votes je
vous apprends rien mais mais on s'était
dit on avait déjà eu des grandes villes
en début de soirée on y retournera un
peu plus tard
on se souvient de qu'est ce qu'on a vu
on a eu le havre
on a eu mais ça qu'on a pas eu
saint-etienne certifiés dans la ville
est plus grande mais on cherchera oui
rambouillet qui était une ville bon
peut-être pas une grande ville mais une
ville de plus haute importance on
n'avait pas eu non plus et donc on n'a
malheureusement pas les résultats
beaumont sur oise mais séverine 9555
habitants c'est pas une grande commune
mais peut-être qu'il ya des problèmes
dans certains bureaux de vote on n'a pas
encore tous les le dépouillement ne sont
pas complètement fait c'est vrai qu'il
ya certaines préfectures parce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe les votes sont
envoyés dans les préfectures qui sont
transmises ensuite au ministère de
l'intérieur va y avoir de la friture sur
la ligne et prendre un peu plus de temps
est-ce qu'on a autre chose d'ailleurs
vous ma vie sur youtube y ait beaucoup
de monde oui nous avons élites qui nous
demandent des résultats dont
hammouche cours et moen ch alors m o n
c'est h bon c'est comme ça dans le 59
absolument le nord qui rend sa première
commune qu'on a eu une mort ouais c'est
vrai on est ravi et c'est marine le pen
qui arrive en tête c'est vrai que le
nord c'est un des fiefs de marine le pen
47 51% des voix c'est un très bon score
on a vu tout à l'heure dans une commune
je me souviens plus le nom de cette
commune elle était à plus de 50% jean
luc mélenchon arrive en deuxième
position score assez faible pour
emmanuel macron 16,47 avec seulement 218
voix est alors regardez fabien roussel
lui qui vient du nord il vient de faire
un bon score il est 4e 5 82% un bon
score évidemment par rapport à celui de
son niveau national je descends comme ça
vous pouvez voir tous les résultats dans
cette commune eric zemmour valérie
pécresse et l'ensemble des douze
candidats c'est philippe routeau avec
seulement quatre voies qui ferment la
marche dans cette commune de monchecourt
nous n'avons pas très bien voter 27 58 %
au niveau de l'abstention
on a fait une communes des dom tom tout
à l'heure oui on peut le refaire on en a
là on en a plus donc voilà je suis dit
aux personnes qui la wii n'hésitez pas
partout et comme l'endroit où on peut
pas pour l'instant c'est les français de
l'étranger on peut pas les trouver nous
sur notre moteur de recherche mais vous
pouvez vous très bien les trouver si
vous allez chercher sur le site du
figaro il ya des papiers très précis par
les journalistes politiques de la
rédaction dites-moi est-ce qu'on a est
ce qu'on a autre chose oui on à dourdan
dourdan et michael caine alors dont cet
argent sur youtube alors vous êtes très
nombreux à nous rejoindre sur youtube
dourdan exactement c'est dans l'essonne
dourdan dans le dans le 91 10 mille 559
habitants et là non plus on n'a pas les
résultats à dourdan alors on est désolé
c'est qui qui est près de qui on
s'excuse on s'excuse auprès de michael
mais quand on s'excuse on s'excuse pour
le ministère de l'intérieur qui ont déjà
pas encore transmis les résultats
exactement mais l on y reviendra a
promis à dourdan vous nous envoyez un
petit message dc10 une demi-heure et
puis et puis on trouve dites moi alors
que je salue parce que je sais qu'on est
à nouveau en direct avec tous les tous
les internautes qui regardent le live le
live de la grande soirée présidentielle
avec bruno dre et vincent redon ici ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on cherche les
résultats de votre commune vous avez les
réseaux au niveau national si vous
transmettez vos demandes de communes sur
les différents chat nous on trouve en
cherchant direct et on vous montre tout
ça on donne un exemple allez d'ailleurs
doublement une commune on a un résultat
quand même allez on va tenter fabienne
sur facebook qui nous demandent des
résultats bien sarreguemines mais on a
déjà cherché sarreguemines au début on
n'avait pas les résultats et on va voir
c'était c'est une des premières communes
que vous m'avez donné à sarreguemines ça
y est ça à sarreguemines en moselle
marine le pen est en tête 30 0 8% bon
score meilleur qu'au niveau national
emmanuel macron à peu près dans le même
score qui le réalise sur l'ensemble des
territoires français jean luc mélenchon
3e éric zemmour quatrième et je descends
pour vous puissiez voir l'ensemble des
résultats à sarreguemines je vais
doucement comme ça vous pouvez voir pour
qui vous allez voter seulement 69 voix
pour philippe poutou qui ferme la marche
dans cette commune de moselle à
l'abstention cartons jaunes 1 dans
l'absence à à sarreguemines abstention
35 24 % n'a pas beaucoup voté c'est
presque un des scores d'abstention les
plus haut qu'on a vu en métropole je
crois depuis le début de cela il me
semble aussi alors dites moi toujours
sur facebook ont haché dit qu'ils nous
demandent c'est dit le mesnil d'accord
c'est matthew louis chedid non vous
savez pas vous allez je sais on arrive à
y va y venir le dites moi le nom de la
commune faisant belle alors le mesnil
llm et enyele comme ça le meilleur
attaché la mine maintenant je regarde et
je les pâtes à c'est tout a lâché la
tâche et le mesnil tir est ministre il
est volé alors vous pouvez le faire les
élèves de chez vous un vous aussi vous
trouvez cette cette page des résultats
elle est très haut sur la page d'accueil
du figaro le mesnil mitri s'est en
meurthe-et-moselle et on a donc là on a
un nouveau record regardez le nombre de
votants à le mesnil
mitri seulement trois voix alors
jusqu'ici des roches fourche à qui
détenait le record avec seulement sept
votants et donc le mesnil mitri je
prends j'ai mon carnet je note je prend
le nom emmanuel macron marine le pen et
règlements ont réalisé le même score à
le mesnil mitri en meurthe-et-moselle je
suis content ça va être difficile
genre de trouver une commune plus petit
c'est quoi on le félicite parce que le
manier le maîtrise était à chedid a
bâché dit bravo à lui le mesnil mitri
donc en meurthe-et-moselle qui prend la
tête de la commune la plus petite avec
le plus petit nombre d'électeurs est ce
qu'on a un abstentionniste dans cette
commune oui en plus on a un
abstentionniste regard des 25 %
d'abstention à le mesnil mitri qui
prendront la tête et donc je barre rouge
pour chats qui a longtemps tenu la barre
sur sept concours à vos approches pour
chats parce que c'était pas évident
exactement il y en a deux autres
concours on voulait rappel pour ceux qui
nous regardent aussi le village le plus
rigolo alors pour l'instant de la glande
âge dans la drôme et puis le pseudo le
plus rigolo c'est la plante verte pour
l'instant qu'on a classé en haut
n'hésitez pas faites nous rire on trouve
des communes un peu rigolade si vous
voulez dites moi on a quelque chose
soyez sérieux un peu la donne l'envié
alors à on va prendre celui de kamel
vite mois sur youtube stains
ce peintre comme ça exactement la liste
1 alors c'est une commune à ces grandes
- oui 38 1636 jamie dont vous voyez
servait ambitieux on a eu des communes
de plus grande taille on a eu tout à
l'heure on le rappelle le havre qui est
nôtre notre phare le havre oui ou non
c'est pas emmanuel macron je sais jean
luc mélenchon qui est arrivé en tête au
havre la ville d'edouard philippe ça
nous un petit peu surpris c'est marrant
à voir mais malheureusement on n'a pas
encore les résultats à ce temps vous
pouvez attendre un petit peu revenir un
peu plus tard le ministère de
l'intérieur transmettra et puis dans
aller une demi heure trois quart d'heure
vous nous renault redemander c'est un on
essaiera de recherche et dites-moi drian
josiane sur facebook qui nous voulons
soir josiane faux seins faux c'est faux
deux sms manqués très simple alors
fausse alors j'ai le fossé avec
éclat ici ici dans le val d'oise et là
aussi mais alors vous me trouvez que des
communes on n'a pas les résultats c'est
pas grave on va aller voir ce qui s'est
passé en 2010 est dans cette commune à
l'époque c'était jean luc mélenchon qui
était en tête devant marine le pen
emmanuel macron c'était très serré à
l'époque on ira voir aussi à fos mais
c'est vrai que des fois on est surpris
on a des villes de 40000 habitants on a
un résultat est ici de 9737 habitants à
force on n'a pas encore le résultat
c'est le ministère de l'intérieur qui
nous transmet tous ces résultats et nous
ils sont ajoutés directement sur la page
du du figaro mais il peut y avoir la
friture sur la ligne entre les résultats
le dépouillement l'envoi dans les
préfectures le renvoie au ministère
l'intérieur l'on voit sur le site du
figaro ça peut prendre du temps on
attend les résultats à fos dites moi une
autre commune adrien villefranche sur
saône alors là aussi vous me demandez
quelque chose ouais alors j'ai un peu
moins de commentaires sur youtube là on
a eu une arrivée soudaine alors
villefranche sur saône c'est quand même
une grande commune dans l'aisne vous me
demandez quel regard des trente six
mille habitants à la différence sur
saône donc j'ai vraiment c'est arrivé
voilà voilà on peut avoir des communes
un peu plus grands jean luc mélenchon
27,20 % des voix il est en tête jean luc
mélenchon dans cette commune juste
devant emmanuel macron moins de cent
voix d'écart entre les deux
villefranche-sur-saône marine le pen est
troisième eric zemmour valérie pécresse
je fais dessinée jusqu'en bas pour que
vous puissiez voir tous les résultats 74
voix pour nathalie arthaud
participation un peu faiblarde en
regarder l'abstention 28,35 % à
villefranche sur saône où c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui est arrivé en tête dans
sept communes dites moi on a autre chose
oui
toujours sur youtube et donnez moi une
petite commune vous avez cela je pense
que c'est une petite communauté pjak gr
et d y avait une petite commune parce
que vous la connaissez pas un regardez
dans la haute-garonne grépiac 991 c'est
une petite commune
26,66 % pour emmanuel macron devant
jean-luc mélenchon et marine le pen
c'est très serré et puis un truc comme
comme à chaque fois on a ce se trouve
entre le troisième et le quatrième s'est
récusé moore qui est quatrième yannick
jadot jean lassalle nicolas dupont
aignan valérie pécresse est derrière
anne hidalgo dans cette dans cette
commune c'est nathalie arthaud qui ferme
la marche avec 3 voix qui nous a demandé
ça
c'était mademoiselle martin sur youtube
et bien mademoiselle martin regarder
dans cette commune abstention très basse
après on les fait si j'ai envie d'aller
voir où et grépiac parce que ça fait un
moment qu'on n'a pas révisé notre notre
géographie grépiac donc un doigt la
garonne c'est au sud de toulouse voilà
un jeu des zooms pour vous vu puissiez
bien voir où et grépiac au sud de
toulouse et peu d'habitants on a 19
cents et quelques voilà grépiac
grippe ont été agréé pia qu'on va partir
à râches cours sur marne rachecourt sur
marne dites moi comment ça c'est bon
secours génère
s'est ouverte et il ya deux jours la
rage course vous voyez en plus c'est
dans le même département de la
haute-marne rachecourt sur marne 7 174
habitants très gros scores de marine le
pen
59,31 % marine le pen crois que c'est le
plus haut score pour un candidat dans
les gants dans l'est dans les communes
de métropole tout à l'heure on a eu un
résultat dans une commune s'est elle au
gosier je crois
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui était
marine le pen fait un très bon score
donc dans cette dans cette commune de
rachecourt sur mare sur marne emmanuel
macron est deuxième avec un score
beaucoup plus faible ce qui est assez
normal jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour
valérie pécresse anne hidalgo est ce que
tout le monde a eu des voix je descend
jusqu'en bas oui le dernier c'est jean
lassalle il a eu une toute petite voix
qui nous a demandé ça
c'était
parce que c'est peut-être le seul votant
pour jean lassalle dans cette commune où
on a voté moyenne des jeux nationale 25
18 % merci julien on rappelle comment ça
marche dit nous adrien comment on fait
pour avoir le résultat pour qu'on puisse
le donner à nos internautes alors vous
êtes sur le sur le live donc que vous
soyez sur lefigaro.fr sur facebook et
sur youtube je vous rappelle qu'on est
sur les trois en même temps vous nous
tapez le nom de votre commune mettez
nous le département avec puisqu'on l'a
vu il ya des noms des noms de nous
serrer par exemple saint-etienne on a vu
un nombre de saint-etienne incalculable
exactement et
on regarde en direct les résultats dans
dans votre commune si on a les résultats
donc c'est très simple juste un
commentaire avec le nom de votre commune
votre département et c'est donc là on
est en live et on ne sera pas en legs
toute la nuit mais vous chez vous avec
cet outil là que je vais vous remettre
dans le chat vous pouvez voulait pas
travailler en fait vous les faire
travailler aux internautes alors qu'on
leur facilite le travail alors on l'a on
l'a en non seulement on a développé cet
outil là donc on facilite effectivement
vraiment le travail mais en plus on a
sur l'application du figaro une
fonctionnalité en fait qui permet de
vous inscrire de donner le nom de votre
commune et dès que les résultats sont
disponibles dans votre commune on vous
envoie une petite note une notification
sur votre téléphone mais vous restez
avec nous quand même où il va quand même
on a on a voilà on passe un meilleur je
vais le garder encore un moment il va me
donner des résultats moi je suis là pour
vous même si c'est un fainéant notre ami
adrien non j'allais aller dit mme patry
fini hanks a besoin on vient de trouver
un commentaire sur la fesse bouc suite
flavio la ville où nous demande la
chaussée saint victor la chaussée saint
victor on a des jolis noms quand même on
pourrait trouver aussi le plus joli
parce que la chaussée-saint-victor qui
ont déjà très joli très élégant oui
alors je vais le noter dans nos
classements dans nos différents concours
la chaussée saint victor pour moi c'est
le plus joli conte à ua a trouvé depuis
la chercher depuis le début dans le
loir-et-cher est formidable chanson le
loir et cher la chaussée-saint-victor
donc emmanuel macron est en tête 36 0 7%
des voix devant marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon eric zemmour évidemment à 6,01
% des voix deux petites voix devant
valérie pécresse et on continue pour que
vous puissiez voir tous les résultats de
tous les candidats à la chaussée saint
victor dans le loir et cher c'est
nathalie arthaud qui ferme la marche
avec 5 voix l'abstention est assez
faible par rapport au niveau national
20,80 2% à la chaussée-saint-victor que
je note comme la plus jolie ville le
plus joli nom de ville je suis assez
d'accord j'ai tenu bon allez moi je suis
prêt à revoir mon jugement je suis sûr
qu'on a allez une petite heure ensemble
encore on va trouver mieux dix mois
or thibault je vois le nom d'une commune
bretonne donc je suis obligé je suis
obligé de la france mais les internautes
rappelle qu adrien et de lorient je suis
de haute savoie tous pride and see donc
il favorise les bretons on avait demandé
est ce qui favorise entre les savoyards
et l'eau c'est faire peu et on n'a pas
eu tant que ça de sa yaris
est bon de misère il vous arrive alors
c'est julia qui nous demande donc plus
neigeait ce
nombre nous on n e vo z
est levé sous des vêtements et des gants
qu'il fait gelé absolue dans mes veines
moëdec alors là est ce qu'on peut faire
plus breton que ce nom là je suis riche
itation suis pas certain regardez le
résultat a donc plus nevez moëdec c'est
marine le pen qui arrive en tête avec 31
27 % des voix devant jean-luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron et troisième temps à
regarder quatrième c'est pas arrivé
souvent on l'a vu ou peut-être une ou
deux fois mais fabien roussel est
quatrième devant eric zemmour jean
lassalle je fais défiler jusqu'en bas
pour vous puissiez voir tous les
résultats jusqu'au bout et c'est donc
nathalie arthaud qui ferme la marche
avec 10 voix attendez je te vois qu'il
ya un bon score de philippe poutou la 2
92% il a fait le même score que valérie
pécresse a pris nevez moëdec on a plutôt
bien loué au tf tension à 21 93 % j'ai
envie de regarder parce que je suis sûr
que c'est très joli
plounévez moëdec parce qu'on peut
regarder on révise notre géographie on
peut même voir des petites photos si
vous voulez à huit décès d'accord c'est
entre morlaix et guingamp plus nevel via
le site de kars mans qui est qui est
tout proche d'accord alors c'est insiste
historique visiblement je vois pas trop
et c'est
d'accord c'est très verdoyant quoi ah
oui une petite
petit ruisseau à plounévez bon bah voilà
alors c'est plus joli qu'on a vu dans un
peu dans cela serait tout à l'heure on a
vu des jolies photos en bretagne dit moi
on a autre chose oui nous avons saverne
dans le bar à saverne dans le bas rhin
il n'y a pas de s à saverne non alors
qu'ils nous demandent ça c'est fabienne
toujours sur
ce n'est pas bon regarder à saverne dans
dans le bas-rhin emmanuel macron est en
tête 32,02 % c'est un bon score par
rapport au niveau national marine le pen
est deuxième devant jean-luc mélenchon
scores à peu près similaire eric zemmour
quatrième yannick jadot qui est à ses
trousses juste derrière avec 347 voix
valérie pécresse nicolas dupont aignan
on descend jean lassalle anne hidalgo
fabien roussel philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud on n'a pas très bien
voter l'abstention 28 82% dans cette
commune du bas rhin de saverne alors il
faut que je prenne le commentaire
youtube de elin qui s'agace un peu
qu'ils aient mis savard il a mis trois
fois evreux alors c'est une grande ville
donc je suis pas sûr qu'on l'ait
d'accord mais il en sait que c'est l'us
open le vaudois avait dit et l'ina et
l'hymne donc livre evreux evreux on a 46
mille habitants des fois on n'a pas
toujours le résultat et l'insee plaisir
ainsi voyez-vous alors les amenons mais
alors il a bien fait d'insister il a
bien fait excuser vous auprès de lui
pendant que je donne les résultats jean
luc mélenchon est en tête dans cette
commune de l'eure d'evreux emmanuel
macron est donc deuxième part in le pen
eric zemmour ça c'est serré 1 entre jean
luc mélenchon emmanuel macron voit dans
cette commune marine le pen eric zemmour
yannick jadot valérie pécresse et on
continue de descendre fabien roussel
jean lassalle et tous les autres c'est
nathalie arthaud encore une fois c'est
souvent philippe poutou et nathalie
arthaud comme au niveau national qui
ferme la qui ferme la marche n'a pas
très bien voter une abstention presque à
30% c'est une grande commune il ya 7000
584 personnes qui se sont abstenus mais
on peut même regardez les les scores
blancs et nuls et on peut même comparé
étonné on va vous montrer à evreux là
c'est jean luc mélenchon devant emmanuel
macron à marine le pen il s'était passé
quoi il ya cinq ans regardez le score au
premier tour et bien c'était emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en tête devant
jean luc mélenchon les choses se sont un
petit peu inversée à evreux en cinq ans
tibou vous allez être à savoyard sur
alors mon différencie la savoie de
haute-savoie j'aimerais vraiment mieux
haut savoyard mais bon allez je vous la
corde ben non alors non gloire en haute
savoie où savoir comment ça s'écrit l
ong est là gl pardon absolu en
haute-savoie rotella je connais pas tous
les laits toutes les villes de haute
savoie et j'en suis désolé qui nous a
demandé ça c'est weiland déjà surfé
béland déjà je suis désolé mais vous
avez bien raison d'habitat noms de l'art
dans ce magnifique département et dans
cette magnifique commune de noms de
l'art où habite 699 habitants et on a
donc les résultats c'est emmanuel macron
qui est en tête devant marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon il ya de gros écarts
un très bon score par emmanuel macron
dans cette commune eric zemmour est
quatrième yannick jadot et donc 5 cm et
puis on continue de descendre valérie
pécresse son sacre savoie c'est un fief
souvent de droite mais le score il n'est
pas forcément très très bon non plus
nicolas dupont aignan jean lassalle
c'est nathalie arthaud une personne a
voté pour nathalie arthaud hannong l'art
on a bien voté en revanche félicitations
aux habitants de l'ong l'art les noms de
l'art doit j'aime bien ce jeu on va
aller chercher ça fait très longtemps
qu'on n'est pas allé chercher ils ont
bien voté 15 37 alors les habitants de
deux noms de l'art et on va déjà regardé
où c'est parce que ça c'est important de
réviser un peu notre notre géographie on
aime bien ça savoir où sont ses communes
c'est 36000 communes je crois que c'est
ça
regardez on est donc à l'ouest d'annecy
hannong l'art et donc les habitants on
va aller chercher parce que c'est parce
que wikipedia est notre ami wikipedia
nous aident et donc je l'avais dit ce
sont bien les noms de l'art bien je
viens voir c'est en petit si
malheureusement c'est d'être un peu
petit pour vous mais sachez que les
habitants de l'ong l'art sont les noms
de l'art bien autre chose oui alors il
faut que je monte un peu sur youtube
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir rappelle que
vous pouvez donner votre le nom de votre
commune sur youtube sur facebook et sur
lefigaro.fr il ya beaucoup de monde ou
en ce moment on est un peu plus de monde
sur youtube allez j'ai trouvé arsène
alors qu'ils nous demandent le pèlerin
dans le 44 ans alors c'est avec deux
ailes ouais le pèlerin dans le 44 il
sort tout de suite 5149 habitants donc
pour cette commune de loire-atlantique
où jean luc mélenchon arrive en tête
devant emmanuel macron et marine le pen
le podium n'est pas respectée dans
l'ordre mais les trois premiers sont en
tête yannick jadot est donc 4e ici
plutôt un bon score pour lui 7,06 % des
voix dans sept communes de
loire-atlantique eric zemmour fabien
roussel valérie pécresse qui arrive donc
derrière le candidat du parti communiste
jean lassalle nicolas dupont aignan et
on descend nathalie arthaud encore une
fois 22 voix seulement 0 74% à plutôt
bien voté 22 % d'abstention aux pèlerins
en loire atlantique alors on va là on va
aller sur le site puisqu'il ya quelques
commentaires qui arrivent nous avons
celui de vigne mais ils nous demandent
alors je ne sais pas comment on prononce
à doite père busque père bus qu'alors pe
chp eux c'est ah oui d'accord cchb eu
excuse dans les 31
alors je les passants s p e ch c'est
peut-être ça pèche plus âprement la
haute-garonne noval à pechbusque alors
pêche plus un petit village 885
habitants et donc emmanuel macron est en
tête dans sept communes de haute garonne
un très bon score c'est peut-être le
meilleur score qu'on a vu depuis le
début pour emmanuel répandant dans les
communes qu'on a regardé 41 points 53%
des voix devant jean-luc mélenchon score
très faible de marine le pen dans cette
commune
9,92 talonné par eric zemmour et on
descend et yannick jadot valérie
pécresse je pense qu'on va avoir dès
tout petit score à la fin parce que
regarder on a des 6% à 7% presque anne
hidalgo jean lassalle nicolas dupont
aignan fabien roussel philippe poutou
nathalie arthaud n'a malheureusement
pour elle pas eu de voix dans cette
commune de pechbusque on a très bien
voter bravo là c'est bravo parce que
seulement 13 % d'abstention à pêche bus
c'est bien joué est-ce qu'on est ce que
vous pouvez relancer nos concours je
rappelle nos concours la ville la plus
rigolote le nom d'îles le plus rigolo
glandage dans la drôme le pseudo le plus
marrant quand nous étions là répondu et
la plante verte on aime bien la plante
verte la plus petite commune seulement
trois votants au mesnil mitri et puis le
nom de ville le plus joli pour l'instant
a déterminé que c'est la chaussée viktor
orban bon c'est un peu subjectif mais on
a trouvé ça joli on peut faire mieux je
sais bien peut faire une très bonne on
de communes là sur facebook alors je
trouve vous me direz thibault
saint-ambroix à saint-ambroix avec un
oui c'est délicat 500 endroits comme ça
avait d'accord alors c'est dans le 30
août andy là c'est saint-ambroix dans le
dans le gardon temps le 30 ans le 30
exactement 3000 à 257 habitants à cet
endroit où marine le pen est arrivé en
tête 37 20 % joli score pour la
candidate du rassemblement national
emmanuel macron est donc deuxième 18
varier le recul 22% devant mélenchon
zemmour la salle roussel pécresse jadot
hidalgo dupont aignan artaud et philippe
poutou donc qui récoltent 13 voix
abstention dans la moyenne nationale
autour de 26 16% dans cette commune de
saint-ambroix du gard alors on a un beau
nom de ville on voit un beau pseudo sur
youtube beaucoup ça alors je les aime
beaucoup je sois silice il est très beau
mais c'est queen dépannage kouyate est
une personne qui commente avec le compte
de son entreprise quinn dépannage wind
essaie de comprendre ce que ça peut
vouloir dire tu es sur bonjour madame
mais kun dépannage c'est la première
fois que je vois ça
alors l on est là pour vous dépanner
aussi puisque si vous n'arrivez pas
trouvé dans d'autres comme le résultat
dans votre commune où on vous le cherche
en vo le trouve alors dans quel mental
fort de ville alfortville grandes villes
ouais grande vie on n'a pas toujours les
résultats sur ce genre de communes
alfortville 44 mille habitants et non
envoyée on n'a pas encore les résultats
alfortville malheureusement on rappelle
quand même dans les plus grandes
communes plus de voix donc plus de temps
pour dépouiller donc plus de temps pour
que le ministère de l'intérieur
transmettre ces données sur sur le site
du figaro et à toutes les personnes au
service qui s'occupe de remplir ces
données au figaro et on les félicite et
on les remercie parce que c'est grâce à
eux qu'on peut tenir ce rendez vous et
vous donner ces résultats et vous
informer sur les résultats dans vos
communes
sur un très très beau même si je trouve
sur facebook man on nous demande mus m
us plus simple efficace c'est dans le
gard également bien sûr
1429 habitants marine le pen arrive en
tête 26 68 % dû faire un bon score dans
le gard marine le pen parce que ça fait
deux communes de suite dans le gard et
deux fois où elle arrive en tête
emmanuel macron et 2e jean luc mélenchon
est troisième eric zemmour très bon
score pour lydie 40% valérie pécresse
jean lassalle et puis je défile jusqu'en
va pour vous puissiez voir tous les
résultats nathalie arthaud ferme la
marche avec 6 voix bonne participation
bravo aux habitants de mu
18,80 % d'abstention seulement alors
j'ai du mal à trouver des pieux type
commun accord on peut on peut chercher
l'allemand alors commencer on essaye on
essaie on est soyez pas défaitiste tout
à l'heure vous êtes fait un peu
enguirlander par un par un internaute
qui voulait avoir une commune que dans
laquelle vous ne croyez pas et on avait
finalement eu les résultats le mans
qu'il faut croire dans la sarthe voilà
le garder je me fais avoir à chaque but
fait confiance au ministère de
l'intérieur emmanuel macron et donc
le candidat sortir en tête au mans 30 22
pour cent c'est un très bon score 1 pour
emmanuel macron surtout pour une grande
commune il n'y a parfois pas pas de
grande différence avec le niveau
national et bien là il fait un très bon
score jean luc mélenchon est donc
deuxième au mans 26
54% marine le pen est donc en troisième
position dans la commune de olivier le
de monsieur le folk les excentrés
m'engage à jouer le prénom de monsieur
le foll du parti socialiste donc anne
hidalgo combien elle fait c'était fans
le foll c'est ça absolument anne hidalgo
2 30% malheureusement pas un très bon
score pour la candidate socialiste comme
un peu partout en france et donc
nathalie arthaud ferment la marche on
n'a pas très bien voter au mans 29 92 %
on se rend compte que dans les grandes
communes on vote peut-être un peu moins
bien là une petite tendance qui se
dégage que dans les petits villages
alors si on attend tellement in game
nous demande si on peut avoir valence
valence veut pourquoi pas valence
j'imagine que c'est plus petit que le
nom 143 milles habitants au mans combien
d'habitants à valence 64000 on a aussi
les résultats il est 23h 26 ans et en
direct et on commence donc à avoir les
résultats de plus grandes communes qui
nous arrive on va essayer de les tenter
un peu plus mais si on n'oublie pas les
gens dans les villages adrien vous c'est
sûr c'est sûr voir on vous rappelle
voilà que c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur qui nous transmet ses
résultats donc évidemment il faut
attendre que ce soit des bouviers que ça
parte au ministère thibault il rappelé
tout à l'heure voilà on commence à avoir
de plus en plus de grandes villes mais
on n'oublie pas les villages et bien
jean luc mélenchon est en tête donc à
valence dans la drôme emmanuel macron
est en deuxième position petit score
pour marine le pen dans cette commune
eric zemmour est donc 4e yannick jadot
5e valérie pécresse et on descend
jusqu'en bas pour que vous puissiez voir
tous les résultats de tous les candidats
nathalie arthaud est malheureusement
dernière 0 56% l'absent seul de
27,73 dans cette commune de la drôme il
ya beaucoup de drômois beaucoup de
communes arroux je pense que c'est ce
qui nous suivent le plus leur donne la
palme c'est vrai et évidemment vos amis
bretons mais je suis sûr que voulait
favoriser ses racines soient ils sont
ils sont alors un peu un poil moins ils
ont tous les bretons adore je sens on
attend toujours des savoyards
si vous cherchez s'il vous plais trouver
donnez nous des villes de savoie et de
haute-savoie pour qu'ils arrêtent de
m'embêter bon allez-y
allez youtube florine nous demandent
trois mois trois mois pour
savoir combien de temps trois mois ouais
ouais alors dit à l'écrire ça devrait
prendre un peu moins de temps mais voyez
jamais il faudrait que vous m'aidiez amo
il est vrai que à m donc ça c'est trois
mois [ __ ] oui exactement [ __ ] trois mois
c'est dans l'armée visiblement vous êtes
sûr que ça se prononce pas travail non
1,7 me suis alors dit nous laurine sur
youtube dites nous comment on dit nous
vite parce que après on oublie on n'a
pas le temps de regarder eh bien
figurez-vous qui a pas l'air encore les
résultats à trois mois donc à trois mois
vous n'avez perturbés et des résultats
vous et c'est particulier on a les
résultats à valence on a eu les
résultats juste avant tous à rouen je
croirais et tramois petite commune de
l'ain 1728 habitants comme on peut le
voir ici on n'a pas encore les résultats
on peut regarder ce qu'il s'était passé
il y à il ya cinq ans dans cette commune
s'est tu et manuel macron qui est arrivé
en tête devant françois fillon et marine
le pen pourrait regarder tout à l'heure
si on cherche à nous autres à moi si on
a les résultats si les choses ont changé
youku nous demande si le comptage n'est
pas terminée pour le second tour alors
il n'a même pas commencé pour le second
tour oui de la présidentielle c'est dans
deux semaines dans deux semaines ouais
c'est ça oui oui non il faut bien
expliquer que la le premier tour vient
de se terminer et donc on votera dans
deux semaines dimanche dans deux
semaines et donc non peut-être qu'il
demandait pour le premier tout semble
200 comptage n'est pas terminée
évidemment il ya certaines communes on
est encore en train de dépouiller parce
que par exemple à paris il ya encore
beaucoup de bureaux de vote qui sont
fermés tard j'imagine des grands bureaux
de vote 23h28 ça doit commencer à se
terminer c'est pour ça qu'on commence à
voir des résultats de plus grande ville
et on attend donc ces résultats qui nous
sont transmis par le ministère de
l'intérieur alors est-ce qu'on va
réussir à trouver une petite commune
elsa sur facebook seront soit reza va
tenter castelnau durban
castelnau durban en art et en ariège
alors que c'était très joli castelnau
donc j'imagine comme ça il ya beaucoup
de cassettes castellino castelnau alors
là c'est déjà regardé leur banc alors il
ya beaucoup de castelnau si vous êtes de
castelnau d'estretefonds d'estrétefonds
c'est plus dur que ça vous pouvez aussi
trouver castelnau durban donc dans
l'ariège et on a les résultats dans
cette commune combien d'habitants ces
petits 452 habitant jean luc mélenchon
est donc en tête devant emmanuel macron
et marine le pen jean lassalle oui c'est
pas très étonnant jean lassalle il
fallait des très bons scores dans toutes
les communes des pyrénées et de l'ariège
13,23 % presque à chaque fois nice est
vrai c'est vrai pour le candidat de
résistants eric zemmour 12 voix 4,67
presque comme un animal mort 11 voix et
puis on descend c'est philippe poutou
avec une toute petite voix à castelnau
durban qui ferme la marche on a plutôt
bien voter regarder l'abstention 21 47%
dans cette commune
une autre petite commune a oui j'aime
bien sur youtube saint-juéry ce1 ce1
juillet alors jury s'est écrit j er y
une fois de plus c'est à dire que le
prénom jury existe
non connaissez des malheureusement non
mais déclaré vous si vous êtes vous
appelez jury ont deux ans cherchera en
priorité votre commune soixante huit
habitants c'est une petite commune mais
ça ne donne pas le record de le mesnil
mitri et ses trois petits votants ces
quatre électeurs il y avait trois
votants donc ici à saint juéry en lozère
c'est emmanuel macron qui est en tête
devant marine le pen et jean lassalle
troisième position première fois qu'il
est aussi aux gens la salle brassens
site il est sur le podium à saint-juéry
devant jean luc mélenchon qui a ri cole
5 petites voix valérie pécresse pareil
fabien roussel eric zemmour ait
plusieurs candidats n'ont pas eu de voix
c'est le cas de nathalie arthaud daigne
d'algos et de philippe poutou seulement
une voix pour yannick jadot et regarde
on a très bien voter non c'est une
petite commune c'est vrai mais seulement
3 abstentionnistes alors la semaine
prochaine non mais on peut faire ça la
semaine prochaine on cherche à nouveau
saint juéry vous vous trouvez dans votre
commune les trois abstentions nist
00 abstentionnistes on n'a pas eu encore
ça devient on n'y a pas eu d'abstention
us dans les petites communes ça peut
arriver mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore trouvé est-ce qu'on a autre chose
alors il ya plusieurs petites communes
qui arriveront donc on va tenter on va
tenter
sotteville-les-rouen
sotteville-lès-rouen à ses tissages
quand je pense que c'est dans la
banlieue de rouen mais alors dites moi
on est sûr qu'elle cite là on est sur
youtube et sur youtube à dans le centre
ville c'est avec caro
forcément je suis mal parti ces pôles de
t sotteville les rouen
exactement il ya soit cette ville en
seine-maritime et c'est jean luc
mélenchon 28 1958 habitants sais pas si
petit que ça saute ville les rouen mais
c'est vrai que c'est une ville moyenne
jean luc mélenchon 30 points 55%
emmanuel macron 25,30 marine le pen et
3e le fameux podium même s'il n'est pas
dans le même ordre qu'au niveau national
yannick jadot eric zemmour fabien
roussel plutôt bien placé à doha hidalgo
et valérie pécresse jean lassalle
nicolas dupont aignan philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud sans voix tout rond
abstention élevée à sotteville
28,81 mais c'est vrai que dans les plus
grandes communes souvent ma une
abstention un peu plus élevée
à l'est ce qu'on avait autre chose à
axel sur facebook axel bonsoir alors bon
axel c'est un garçon une fille c'est un
garçon à villiers sur marne et villiers
sur marne
alors il ya beaucoup de villiers comme
vous pouvez le voir vous pouvez le faire
chez vous ainsi adrien vous boycott sur
les réseaux sur les différents chat vous
pouvez aller sur le site du figaro.fr et
vous tapez vous avez tout de suite sans
cette page vous trouvez les résultats
vous tapez le nom de votre commune à
villiers sur marne on n'a pas encore les
résultats voyez il ya vingt-huit 1592
habitants c'est quand même une grande
commune est là dans cette commune
lendemain malheureusement pas encore les
résultats alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
trouver comme dit mois devenant un
membre a dit sûre d'avoir des résultats
beaucoup et maintenant j'ai soif alors
j'en profite et pour chercher qu'est-ce
qu'on peut avoir ici sur youtube vous
pouvez expliquer aux gens aussi comment
on fait parce que ça c'est important
s'ils veulent avoir leur commune ouais
si vous nous rejoignez sur le chat donc
que vous soyez sur le site internet du
figaro sur youtube ou sur facebook vous
ne rentrez le nom de la commune avec le
département et nous on entre ça dans le
moteur de recherche tout simplement
alors évidemment votre ville est petite
plus on peut avoir les résultats
facilement et rapidement on commence à
avoir les résultats dans plusieurs
grandes villes on a réussi à en trouver
donc n'hésitez pas ben justement à
l'installer vivement un site du figaro
alors c'était un anonyme qui nous
demandent les se cachent pas ils se
cachent donc il ne réglera pas la palme
du meilleur pseudo maintenant c'est vrai
que alors le meilleur ce dos pour
l'instant on est sur la plan derrière
son ibook d'autres d'autres pseudos
exode fait ce lieu à n'hésitez pas alors
dites moi cet anonyme ils nous demandent
chambourcy chambourcy
chambre69 exactement les yvelines une
ville dans les unes ainsi tout à l'heure
en bout y est c'est vrai emmanuel macron
très bons scores à chambourcy 41 75 % et
alors là il ya un vrai écart avec avec
les autres candidats parce que regarder
jean luc mélenchon et qui à 14,28 mais
beaucoup de candidats autour de ce score
très bon score de valérie pécresse c'est
vrai que les yvelines c'est un fidèle
des républicains elle arrive en
quatrième position juste derrière marine
le pen très bon score évidemment par
rapport à son score au niveau national
eric zemmour est allé ensuite on aura
yannick jadot jean lassalle nicolas
dupont aignan les plus petits candidats
c'est fabien roussel anne hidalgo
philippe poutou et nathalie arthaud dans
cette commune on a plutôt bien rester à
chambourcy 21 points 56% monsieur
l'anonyme vous voilà comblés vous avez
les résultats dans votre commune
thibault nous avons un savoyard et par
amour ça doit si on a une gloire tout à
l'heure en tête alors c'est vrai c'est
alors le deuxième savoyard c'est à smara
qui nous demande on jouera ce soir 23h35
on est en direct évidemment vous le
rappelle hayon le jus hayon up crois que
c'est comme ça lyon le vieux up est-ce
qu'on n'irait pas voir à lyon le jeune
juste après ce qu'on vote pareil à un
hayon le vieux et à lyon le jeune sa
théorie on va on va voir ça alors c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui arrive en tête
dans cette petite commune devant
emmanuel macron et marine le pen on se
souvenait vous de ce podium 1 parce que
je veux aller voir ce qui se passe à
lyon le jeune marine le pen yannick
jadot eric zemmour valérie pécresse jean
lassalle on descend jusqu'en bas pour
vous puissiez avoir tous les scores et
c'est donc une commune où on a plutôt
bien voter l'abstention et seulement 15%
à hayon donc le vieux jean luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron marine le pen sk à lyon
le jeune on a voté de la même manière ça
doit pas être bien loin de toute façon
ça à lyon le jeune regardons si et
ballon figurez vous qu'à à lyon le jeune
on va les jeunes votre vote plus pour
emmanuel macron que les yeux de haillons
figurez-vous jean luc mélenchon est
deuxième devant marine le pen personne
nous a demandé les résultats d'ailleurs
le jeune donc on va pas les boulevards
pas perdre de temps mais on voit qu'à
des petites différences des communes qui
sont côte à côte dit mme en autre chose
oui
alors j'avais
alors on va tenter il ya six sur youtube
qui nous demandent les résultats dans
rue r eu lieu dans ces 80 120 le code
postal rue oui ça existe jusqu'ici on
s'est pas fait avoir rue de rue
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir des
communes à côté il s'appelle comme ça
vous savez vous avez des rues saint
denis par un pari pour les rues de rue
bon peut-être eh bien figurez vous qu'à
rue donc dans la somme c'est marine le
pen qui arrive en tête avec 39 92 % des
voix un très bon score devant emmanuel
macron qui est dans son score à peu près
de la moyenne nationale beaucoup plus
bas jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour
valérie pécresse et je descend jusqu'en
bas on regarde tous les résultats
ensemble pendant qu adrien cherche la
prochaine commune parce que c'est
important on va essayer d'en donner le
plus possible on reste encore une petite
demi heure ensemble pour voir plein de
résultats nicolas dupont aignan nathalie
arthaud anne hidalgo philippe poutou
seulement quatre petites voix abstention
dans la moyenne nationale
25,57 % d'abstentionnistes arue drôle de
villerupt drôle de ville j'ai trouvé
d'autres comme il dit alors ça fait
plusieurs fois sur facebook que quentin
demande lourdios lourde jamais alors
lourdios c'est la commune de jean
lassalle nom est une mordue aussi faire
il semble lourdios ichère ouais c'est ça
ouais c'est ça arrive bien regarder
lourdios ichère alors est-ce que
les commandes il et les cohabitants de
jean lassalle ont voté pour jean
lassalle
oui jean lassalle plébiscite pour jean
lassalle à lourdios ichère chez lui
alors au mans il peut rentrer comme le
roi du pétrole 74 voix
65,49 m'en sors je crois que c'est le
plus haut score quand on a eu pour
l'instant ils sont que c'est donc jean
lassalle qui fait un score
ah oui non mais là très impressionnant
devant emmanuel macron j'ai 50 ans
rappelle jean lassalle et habib sy a été
maire je crois qu'il est toujours maire
d'ailleurs n'ont ils pas mer puisqu'il
est députée mme il a été maire pendant
des années de lourdios ichère et donc
ensuite on descend vous avez tous les
résultats dans cette commune des
pyrénées atlantiques zéro voix pour
nathalie arthaud pour eric zemmour tient
zéro voix pour eric zemmour c'est pas
commun yannick jadot zéro voix nicolas
dupont-aignan 0 voit également on a bien
voté alors dit aussi cher très impliquée
pour pour jean lassalle pour le poulain
du village 13,64 % seulement
d'abstention qu'est ce qu'on a ici et
sur youtube nous avons maison mais alors
il ya y qu'elle serbie et ma
grave quand même alors je connais dans
d'autres départements dans le calvados
la première fois qu'on a une ville du
calvados il est 23h30 8 en étant direct
et amusé cette petite commune de 365
habitants c'est donc emmanuel macron qui
arrive en tête avec 29 25 % des voix 22%
pour marine le pen 17 pour jean luc
mélenchon assez représentatif de ce qui
se passe au niveau national eric zemmour
est 4e valérie pécresse est cinquième
avec une toute petit vol de plus que
jean lassalle yannick jadot fabien
roussel dupont aignan hidalgo poutou
arthaud arthaud nathalie arthaud une
toute petite voix la candidate de lutte
ouvrière et bravo parce que la 9 76% peu
d'abstentionnistes à méze et dans le
calvados si vous voulez voir où c'est
parce que c'est vrai qu'on fait ça aussi
un mezze dans le dans le calvados en
place sur une carte de france où se
trouve mezze mais et c'est au sud ouest
de caen voilà vous savez tout
toujours sur youtube
- juste après mais nous avons bon du bo
nds ont dû 59 on a vu que dans là on
avait souvent de très bons scores pour
marine le pen et fabien roussel aussi
qu'ils faisaient des scores plus élevés
qu'au niveau national on va voir si ça
se confirme et bien non à bondues
regarde le score des manuels macron il
est très impressionnante 50 78 % pour
emmanuel macron je crois que c'est le
meilleur score qu'on a vu pour le
président candidat est on avec l'armée
pour cent varane online semble il me
semble il me semble à bondues marine le
pen est deuxième avec évidemment un
score beaucoup plus fun 11,93 valérie
pécresse tient sur le podium dans cette
commune devant eric zemmour jean luc
mélenchon et ça marche pas trop à
bondues un nom 97,17 % yannick jadot
nicolas dupont aignan jean lassalle à
jeu décent jusqu'en bas fabien roussel
anne hidalgo nathalie arthaud philippe
poutou abstention hausse est faible 22
21 % à bondues dans le nord qui nous a
demandé ça vous savez bondues c'est je
remonte c'est charles bonsoir charles
voilà vous avez des résultats dans votre
commune alors je vous rappelle par ce
qui va nous reste une petite demi heure
maximum que dans nos concours nos
concours très important de la ville du
nom de ville le plus drôle glandage est
en tête dans la drôme vous êtes toujours
d'accord avec moi toujours d'accord le
nom le pseudo le plus rigolo qu'on a eu
on a bien aimé plantes vertes on a du
mal à l'imaginer se déplacer voter le
mesnil mitri et la plus petite commune
qu'on a eu à chercher avec seulement
trois votants pour quatre inscrits le
mais dimitri où il ya eu 33 % pour
emmanuel macron pour jean luc mélenchon
mais pour marine le pen ar en plus ils
sont quatre ils sont pas d'accord dans
la même veine et puis le nom plus jolie
pour l'instant alors ça c'est subjectif
mais on a bien aimé la chaussée victor
on est assez d'accord
chaussée non merde t'as essayé de
trouver encore lui fait mieux alors là
on a fait beaucoup du tube on va
repartir un peu sur facebook et on peut
essayer peut-être un peu des grandes
villes maintenant si vous voulez alors
là qu'est ce que n'ont pas forcément
vous me donnez ce que vous avez
allez-vous voir voir à voiron dans
l'isère
par une grande ville mais oui on le sait
déjà un brin plus grande envergure 20
1248 habitants et donc on a les
résultats à voiron c'est emmanuel macron
qui est en tête devant jean luc
mélenchon score un peu plus faible qu'au
niveau national pour marine le pen c'est
yannick jadot qui est en quatrième
position à voiron
eric zemmour est en cinquième juste
derrière valérie pécresse anne hidalgo
fabien roussel jean lassalle nicolas
dupont aignan philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud 0 52% des voix
abstention dans la moyenne nationale 25
87 dans cette commune de voir ont
été ré qui a fait des émules sur
facebook d'eau qu'on a on ad'autres
demandons à celle de et ja demandent les
résultats draps à lutzelhouse alors ça
c'est cool à la lead the loose alors
j'ai pas le droit de me rater je souffre
n'allons et moi non plus parce que là on
a une vraie pression lutzelhouse alors
c'est laissez moi et ça y est c'est moi
faisant un essai de l une des
z
mais c'est moi qui france malaisie
continue aux élus de loose attendait
commence à peser fait à la fin non je
suis pas là rien qui sort alors dites
moi j'ai alors commencé à lutter mais
jalu du malawi non mais c'est vous oui
alors dz euh ouais ah bah oui oui ici
ont tous explique quand on voit le
département de lutte lutzelhouse non je
ne sais pas comment on glisse dans le
bar a alors à huit ce loose on a eu
marine le pen en tête de ce premier tour
32,23 % des voix 24.52 pour emmanuel
macron 16 pour jean luc mélenchon c'est
eric zemmour qui est donc 4e yannick
jadot jean lassalle on descend jusqu'en
bas vous avez tous les résultats je vous
préviens tout de suite on va aller
regarder comment s'appellent les
habitants de lutzelhouse
on est donc jusqu'en basse et philippe
poutou qui avec seulement quatre voix
ferme la marche 22 66 %
d'abstention alors il faut savoir le
réécrire mais je sais maintenant l ut z
eu l h aux usa je suis aidé et je fais
des lutzelhouse alors lutteuse regardez
où ça a l'air très volubile nous emmène
jolies photos c'est à l'ouest de
strasbourg regard des années comme ça
l'air beau à lutzelhouse en aidant les
montagnes et ses superbes à là on a le
plus beau paysage théâtral et de ce fait
vrai là c'est très assez facilement
l'air ouais ouais alors là bravo à
lutzelhouse parce que ça a l'air très
beau et donc on va voir le gentilé
d'aidé de lutzelhouse ce sont les luttes
c'est loossois et les luttes celle où
d'oise une sorte de simplicité c'est
assez normal voilà on embrasse tous les
lutzelhouse d'oise et tous les élus de
selous voit comment il s'appelait notre
alors c'était et jacky demandé ça
l'était pour sa cousine julia voilà vous
pouvez demander pour vos grands parents
par exemple pas forcément très bien
servir d'internet il nous écrive y
demande et on cherche pour eux
alors vous êtes assez timide sur
facebook il faut retourner sur youtube
on va prendre cantine aux cantines aux
54 on a eu tellement de 20
effectivement on va aller voir les
résultats de ces chants s y
chm ps
chandrayaan-1 asséchant comme ça
effectivement sinon c'est exactement la
meurthe et moselle bien sûr et donc à
ses chances et emmanuel macron qui
arrive en tête 32
78% des voix marine le pen est 2e jean
luc mélenchon et 3e le même podium qu'au
niveau national avec un score un peu
plus élevés quand même pour emmanuel
macron par rapport au niveau national
eric zemmour yannick jadot va souvent
cette récurrence c'est souvent l'un ou
l'autre qui squattent la quatrième place
le plus souvent évidemment eric zemmour
valérie pécresse anne hidalgo jean
lassalle dupont aignan roussel poutou
arthaud avec 21 une voie moyenne
nationale pour l'abstention 24,48 % à
ses champs
voilà pour continuer 54 je connais des
gens qui parce qu'on peut le dire aussi
sur le site vous mais pas trop trouvé
sur le site s qui sont timides sur le
site il n'y a pas trop de commentaires
sur le site
alors ils sont nombreux mais il ne
commande pas donc dessiné dit alors on
peut pour nous poser des questions vous
réponds sur autre chose enfin bon on est
quand même là pour donner des résultats
mais dites moi on peut peut-être
répondre à magali donc il nous demande
si on a des français de l'étranger on a
déjà répondu à cette question mais
c'était une fausse alerte rejoindre au 2
août avec nous et nous demander les
résultats en californie alors sur le
moteur de recherche qu'on utilise qui
est sur le site du figaro.fr on n'a pas
encore mis les résultats des français de
l'étranger mais les journalistes
politiques du figaro donc si vous allez
sur le site dans la partie politique on
fait des articles à ce sujet donc vous
pourrez y retrouver ces résultats là
mais sur le site voila on voit aussi
vovo demande vos questions donc
n'hésitez pas est-ce qu'on se recentre
est pas une grande ville ouais alors
regardez je suis en train de chercher
donc les résultats à paris dans le 5e
arrondissement mais évidemment c'est un
peu trop tour n'a pas encore les
résultats mais donnez-moi une autre
grande ville d'autun allons-y quelque
chose alors lyrique sur youtube nous
demande brest brest 1 pourquoi pas brest
vous favorisez encore nos amis bretons
je vois ça mais pourquoi pas bresse cent
trente neuf mille habitants et on a les
régions da à brest c'est donc emmanuel
macron qui est en tête devant jean luc
mélenchon c'est très serré entre les 2
28% tous les deux à peine 300 voix
d'écart c'est marine le pen qui est 4e
yannick jadot 5e tu fais aussi des bons
scores de mon score par rapport à son
niveau national en bretagne eric zemmour
est 5e valérie pécresse anne hidalgo
fabien roussel jean lassalle nicolas
dupont aignan philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud on n'a pas très bien
voter à brest mais comme souvent dans
les grandes villes 28,33 % d'abstention
dans cette commune donc du finistère
brest peut-être la plus grande commune
qu'on a eu 1 depuis le début même sens
mais je crois que je crois bien tout va
bien
alors là on a le nom d'une ville que
j'aime beaucoup alors qu'ils thibault va
alors est-ce que c'est mieux que la
chaussée victor qui est pour l'instant
la plus jolie villa con et je trouve je
trouve ça mieux à ses belles filles sur
facebook delphine bon furs est fixé dans
le 48 c'est saint flour de mercoire ah
bah alors la wii la wii la wii on est
désolé pour les habitants de la chaussée
victor mais saint flour de comment saint
flour de mercoire alors on va le
chercher saint flour alors saint cloud
floor fo unef elle aurait donné mais
revoir mais c'est superbe alors ça c'est
superbe bravo
ne
fournaise bleus on peut faire gagner on
va chercher alors à saint flour de
mercoire qui remporte notre grand
concours pour l'instant qui prend la
tête parce que c'est pas fini la plus
jolie commune plus jolis noms de
communes c'est marine le pen qui est en
tête 40 et une voix devant jean lassalle
deuxième il fait pas aussi bien qu' à
lourdios ichère où on rappelle tout à
l'heure on a cherché dans sa commune a
fait 67 pour visiter cinq jours la salle
mais aujourd'hui c'est jean lassalle
fait un très bon score donc ici à saint
flour de mercoire 18 points 54% score un
peu plus faible pour emmanuel macron
examen m devant jean-luc mélenchon ça
marche pas trop en lozère pour jean luc
mélenchon en tout cas dans cette commune
de saint flour yannick jadot valérie
pécresse je descend jusqu'en bas fabien
roussel anne hidalgo philippe poutou
nicolas dupont aignan nathalie art on a
bien voté à saint flour de mercoire
regarder 16 13% je note le nom en entier
pour pas l'oublier parce que pour
l'instant saint flour de mercoire c'est
vraiment très jolie personne n'a trouvé
plus rigolo que glandage pour l'instant
pour l'instant
qu'est ce qu'on a
pendant que vous cherchez une nouvelle
commune je vais regarder ou et saint
flour de mercoire et comment on appelle
les habitants de saint flour de mercoire
gardé un fort de mes records ah oui
c'est alors qu'elle est la plus grande
ville proche de saint flour de mercoire
on est loin oui d'accord on est on est
au oui je comprends c'est très perdu ses
dents la lauze à fins et très perdu
on aime beaucoup ses coins de france qui
sont magnifiques et évidemment saint
flour de mercoire comment on a tous un
oui mais j'imagine que c'est superbe et
donc on appelle les habitants le saint
flour de mercoire les symphorien tout
simplement tout ça delphine on vous
embrasse
aller où est-ce qu'on peut partir
maintenant
alors on va partir à la seyne-sur-mer la
seyne-sur-mer dans le var il semble à la
seyne-sur-mer
pas les résultats la seyne sur mer 62
mille habitants c'est quand même une
grande commune donc c'est vrai que dans
les grandes communes on a les résultats
un peu plus tard même si on rappelle
qu'on a eus brest 1 tout à l'heure en
est sûrs ou en aussi donc on a eu on a
eu des communes comme ça on n'a pas
encore la seyne-sur-mer malheureusement
mais vous pouvez chercher on va rester
encore une vingtaine de minutes ensemble
donc c'est maintenant à pour de demander
vos résultats adrien pour qu'on puisse
les chercher la seyne-sur-mer
probablement pas le temps d'y revenir et
vous cherchez un peu plus tard vous
pouvez même mettre votre mail dans l'une
des pages d'accueil du sur la page
d'accueil du sia rouge croit et on vous
envoie les résultats dès que ça tombe
dès que le ministère de l'intérieur nous
les transmettre et sur l'application du
physio également
alors emmanuel nous demande si c'est
fini non ça n'est pas fini et n'ont donc
on va ces manuels maquereau en personne
non même pas
si une demande le touquet c'est que
c'est game annuel macro nord à l'horizon
me croire on aurait fui qua non alors
avançons allons voir alençon 25000
habitants dans cette commune de l'orne
et donc c'était manuel macron qui arrive
en tête avec 31% des suffrages devant
jean-luc mélenchon et marine le pen
l'ordre est inversé par rapport au
niveau national eric zemmour est 4e
yannick jadot valérie pécresse on
descend je vous fais défiler jusqu'en
bas pour vous puissiez voir tous les
candidats dans cette commune d'alençon
on a mal voté en revanche à alençon vous
voyez 32 54 % mal voté attention on a
peu voté je me permettrais pas de juger
pour qui ont voté les habitants
d'alençon
alors on était la seyne-sur-mer tout à
l'heure on va on va partir juste à côté
c'est jean-françois sur facebook qui
nous demandent saint cyr sur mer à saint
cyr alors j'espère qu'ils ont mieux
travaillé saint cyr alors il faut que je
tape en dents de scie je suis inséré la
vue c'est un sirh sûr mais on espère que
dans le var attention sinon carton rouge
la préfecture du var si on n'a pas eu
encore les résultats à saint cyr et ne
toujours pas alors que je teste dans le
var ya certaines communes où les
résultats ne remonte pas assez vite donc
on n'a pas non plus les résultats à
saint-cyr-sur-mer malheureusement mais
dans le var essayer encore parce qu'on
va trouver une commune du var pas loin
de chez vous résultat on à toulon alors
à bon là vous vous dites qu'on n'a pas
eue saint seiya et la seyne sur mer et
qu'on pourrait avoir toulon j'ai du mal
à y croire mais peut-être peut-être
peut-être essayé on a eu des grandes
communes tout à l'heure malheureusement
on n'a pas non plus les résultats tout
mais c'est une grande ville 1 176
1198 d'habitants en 2018 regardez en
2017 qui est arrivé en tête à toulon
c'était marine le pen devant françois
fillon emmanuel macron on peut voir ça
aussi si vous cherchez donc comparé et
on va comparer la prochaine ville de
mémoire une ville ou un village louis
alors on à charles qui nous demandent
collioure dans les pyrénées bien sûr
collioure cgi nous dit beau village
voilà peut-être pouvoir voir à vous les
cons montré des images de collioure oui
c'était manuel macron qui est en tête
regarder devant marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon eric zemmour et 4e valérie
pécresse jean lassalle yannick jadot on
descend jusqu'en basse et philippe
poutou qui ferme la marche
abstention dans la moyenne nationale 26
45 mêmes qu'au lourd je vous avais dit
je vous les comparez alors regardez
emmanuel macron marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon parce qu'on peut faire ça
à collioure est ce que ça a changé par
rapport à il ya cinq ans oui c'était
françois fillon en tête bon en soi
fillon qui n'est plus là et ensuite
emmanuel mâcon marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon c'est à dire que les voix de
la droite ne se sont pas reportées un
peu comme au niveau national sur valérie
pécresse vous voulez voir des images de
collioure je voulais bon allons-y allons
d'ailleurs à collioure on n'a pas eu un
très bon score de jean lassalle qui fait
souvent des bons résultats dans ce genre
de dans ce genre de communes
dans les pyrénées notamment collures
regardez comme c'est tout proche de
perpignan on a ces magnifiques photos de
collioure alors là pour le coup on
pourrait partir en vacances à collioure
vous étiez pas emballé tout à l'heure
dans certaines communes que je vous
propose est là je le suis à lola le
breton était emballé mais en 6ème on
peut pas partir en vacances parce qu'on
refait sa la semaine prochaine il nous
reste encore un petit quart d'heure
ensemble et puis la semaine prochaine on
revient pour retrouver les résultats au
deuxième tour également collioure
superbe ville qui est probablement la
plus jolie pour l'instant qu'on a eu à
avoir quand on est allé chercher un peu
sur sur les différents villages dites
moi alors lille où nous demande sur
youtube roubaix est apprécié c'est le
pen comme tous les nordistes
pratiquement alors on va vérifier
allons-y alors roubaix qui a été au
centre de l'actualité on le sait pendant
plusieurs semaines avec ce fameux
reportage et on va voir le résultat
roubaix c'est une grande ville aussi pas
certain qu'on ait pas certains résultats
roubaix allons-y c'est jean luc
mélenchon grands voiliers qui est assez
lille où emma l'île où s'est également
trompé en troisième position voilà jean
luc mélenchon très bon score 52 points
50% des voix à roubaix et emmanuel
macron et donc 2e marine le pen est en
troisième position eric zemmour score un
peu plus faible mais c'est normal quand
un candidat fait un très gros scores
souvent derrière ça tombe assez vite
yannick jadot valérie pécresse fabien
roussel et on descend petit à petit
jusqu'à philippe poutou
regardez l'abstention à roubaix
extrêmement élevé c'est probablement ce
qu'on a vu plus élevé en métropole
depuis le début presque 41 %
d'abstention dans cette commune de
roubaix dans le nord
qui recevra évidemment c'est
paris-roubaix c'est la semaine prochaine
ne sais pas si vous êtes fan de cyclisme
on suivra ça évidemment sur le figaro
live et aujourd'hui on parle de
politique allons-y quart d'heure
ensemble ouais
ai-je a toujours sur facebook
d'améliorer l'anr ville tha
[Musique]
tamerhosni2010 login s'allumant
tamerville
alors nous on n'a pas les résultats une
petite commune en rien ce sens aux 13,9
habitants toujours surprenante pas avoir
les résultats dans certaines petites
communes on va déjà il faudra grâce à
cet outil là vous pourrez aller sans
doute la voir dans peu de temps on a
autre chose
c'est le moment parce que ne nous reste
plus beaucoup de temps ensemble fait
nouveau demander cher gens l'ont compris
et elles sont sexy envoyé par les deux
communes alors ici ne choisissez pas
avec votre coeur choisissez avec
chercher un peu partout en france a fait
au hasard
mulatière vous êtes
matière en 69 nul à tir d'adam le 69 la
mêlée retire la mulatière exactement
3495 habitants et donc c'était manuel
macron dans cette commune du rhône qui
arrive en tête 32 81% devant jean-luc
mélenchon marine le pen se faire un
score beaucoup plus faible que au niveau
national elle est seulement troisième
seulement évidemment par rapport à son à
sa deuxième place au niveau national
eric zemmour 9 51% des voix lui il est
un peu plus au contraire valérie
pécresse yannick jadot fabien roussel
jean lassalle pas de surprise pour les
candidats avec les scores les plus
faibles nicolas dupont aignan anne
hidalgo philippe poutou et nathalie
arthaud abstention assez faible 23 92 %
à cette faible en tout cas par rapport
au niveau national
alors leeds sur le site du figaro ce qui
est de plus en plus allongée sur le site
du figaro favorisant par vous les
motiver pas de
mauvais élève sur le site c'est rock
solide ce qui nous précise que dans les
ici c'est paris 10 sont disponibles donc
on peut que c'est pas vrai c'est leur
allons voir paris vième arrondissement
de paris il est allé voir avant nous ni
la raison et il s'en va l'embaucher il
va venir la semaine prochaine pour ne
dire regardez dans le 6e arrondissement
de paris c'est emmanuel macron qui
arrive qui arrive en tête c'est souvent
la droite qui arrive en tête dans sept
arrondissements notamment lors des
élections municipales
emmanuel macron est donc en tête 47 62%
devant jean-luc mélenchon eric zemmour
est donc troisième et on le voit à paris
et on pas forcément très détaillée mais
regardez toujours pas de marine le pen
non non non non non elle arrive
seulement 1 2 3 4 5 6 ème marine le pen
derrière nianing jadot avec 4 % des voix
dans le 6e arrondissement et anne
hidalgo la maire de paris bon c'est vrai
que c'est pas forcément un
arrondissement qui votent pour elle
habituellement même à paris mais quand
même c'est pas un très bon score est
alors allons voir par exemple paris xii
qui est souvent plus favorable à la
gauche paris xiième arrondissement
puisque leeds nous indique qu'il est
possible d'avoir les résultats et nous a
menti alors il lui il peut réaliser dans
10e à ces 10e pardon alors je m'excuse
auprès d'eux de leeds et regarder dans
le 10ème arrondissement là c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui est en tête 38,45 très
bon score devant emmanuel macron devant
yannick jadot on voit la sociologie
parisienne la droite a beaucoup plus de
mal eric zemmour à 5,22 marine le pen
score très très bas par les piètres 24%
valérie pécresse anne hidalgo là non
plus même même à paris elle fait pas un
très bon score la maire socialiste de la
capitale fabien roussel jean lassalle
nicolas dupont aignan philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud sont représentés
seulement et qui est représenté
seulement 1 114 voix on a bien voté dans
le 10e arrondissement de paris on dit
souvent un pari on n'a pas très bien
voter rien des 21 53 % d'abstention
seulement on commence à voir donc des
grandes villes oui
alors j'ai
injection motive c'est parce qu'en fait
je re super parce que pour l'instant
qu'on préfère depuis le début de cette
soirée c'est la plante verte vous êtes
en train de me dire qu'il ya mieux c'est
moi qui vais devoir trancher oui moi je
steam que c'est mieux mais alors il
attend jeu on est 2 doigts un moment ou
un autre il faut un chef c'est vous qui
dites moi à la panzer c'est dream
timothée a pas my dreams timothée né
tout à l'heure on a eu 4 à strophes way
catastrophe
dream timothée c'est pas mal parce que
il ya un jeu de mots et là on élève un
peu le niveau alors dream thimoté je
vais réfléchir pour savoir si je le
ferai sans trêve ni aux plantes vertes
vont vous dire en quelques minutes alors
lui nous demande by montigny donc bib et
hideuse et l'irak billy billy billy il
ya beaucoup de billy-montigny rien et je
les trouvais juste ici billy-montigny
billy-montigny c'est dans le pas de
calais comme on peut le voir et donc
c'est marine le pen qui arrive en tête
assez largement là aussi 1,5015 27% des
voix jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel macron
très faible lui c'est peut-être l'inde
est l'une des dix communes où il a fait
le score le plus faible depuis qu'on
regarde presque deux heures qu'on
n'entende plus de deux heures un 2h10
qu'on est ensemble fabien roussel fait
un très bon score on l'a dit dans le
nord et dans le pas de calais fabien
roussel fait des scores plus élevés en
tout cas est mieux classé que son score
au niveau national eric zemmour yannick
jadot à l'épée crash je descends vous
avez comme souvent les mêmes candidats
qui ferment marche c'est nathalie
arthaud ici qui est dernière avec 20
voix on a voté moyennement 1
on n'a pas trop trop on sait pas trop
déplacé à billy-montigny
27,81 2 % d'abstention dans cette
commune du pas de calais je vais quand
même aller voir regarder par rapport à
2010 est est ce que marine le pen a fait
mieux ou moins bien qu'à l'époque elle a
fait mieux 45 qui régule 96% pour à
l'époque c'était déjà jean luc mélenchon
qui était arrivé deuxième il ya cinq ans
alors nous a quelque chose pour moi ou
pas oui on a alors un à charles qui
l'expert des plus beaux villages de
france ce soir et qui nous demande les
résultats à saint-georges-de-didonne 5
c'est joli c'est très un georges de
didonne alors ça passe pas devant saint
flour de mercoire parce que ça s'est
très c'était très joli saint georges de
didonne alors didonne des gelées je les
ai regardés singe c'est facile c'est
parfait on a bossé ils ont félicité les
développeurs évidemment alors à saint
georges de didonne vous êtes pas dit où
c'est en charente maritime emmanuel
macron très bon score pour lui 35 68 %
marine le pen est deuxième le podium est
respecté dans l'ordre pas tout à fait
les mêmes pourcentages qu'au niveau
national jean luc mélenchon est
troisième eric zemmour valérie pécresse
et nick shadow jean lassalle assez
représentatif en terme de classement
cette commune la dupont aignan fabien
roussel anne hidalgo nathalie arthaud
philippe poutou évidemment 22 %
d'abstention les gens se sont déplacés à
saint georges de didonne en charente
maritime c'est pas vrai avoir livré sa
ressemble
en fait dès que dès que le nom vous
intéresse vous avez envie de savoir
alors je vais retourner en écharpe
précise que c'était un très beau village
c'est surtout parce que tout à l'heure
charles nous c'est lui qui nous a
proposé collioure tout à l'heure oui
alors regardez je veux aller chercher
saint georges et beaucoup de saint jean
saint georges de didonne
on y va c'est parti à 7 au bord de la
mer mais encore et charges sociales mais
d'accord de mer regardez en a d'accord
on est au bout au bout
danseur séquelles département lundi
charente maritime aux essais ça voulait
voir des photos oui je suis venu ici
pour ça c'est magnifique ça vous plaît
ouais c'est regarder moi c'est le bleu
regardez-moi moorea non mais alors moi
j'ai une petite préférence pour conclure
que je pense qu il fait meilleur mais
bon on peut si vous savez c'est
peut-être une plage un peu plus
d'automne ça c'est plus bucolique
on a en tout cas on a le choix bon c'est
vrai qu'on a le choix et on peut même
faire de l'accrobranche regarder à saint
georges de didonne ce conte ou le néo
résulte des résultats aux gens c'est ça
qui les intéresse oui c'est aujourd'hui
de tourisme madrid a installé une
dizaine de minutes ensemble de nouveaux
donneurs allons-y on prend la demande de
rémy viroflay vivre aux airs os comme ça
exempts les yvelines aussi 0 flay et
après on essaiera essayer de nous
demander quelques plus grande commune si
vous voulez parce qu'il est minuit
minuit 2 en étant direct et on a
probablement des communes de plus grande
importance en terme de population et on
aura peut-être des résultats sur
certaines d'entre elles à viroflay c'est
emmanuel maintenant qui tentent être
très bon score 38 80% des voix jean-luc
mélenchon et
deuxième valérie pécresse troisième
tiens c'est une commune on a vu dans les
yvelines ça marchait plutôt bien plutôt
mieux en tout cas qu'au niveau national
pour valérie pécresse eric zemmour
yannick jadot et là aussi marine le pen
aller un peu plus loin si j'avais une
40% des voix après sa chute un jean
lassalle hidalgo roussel dupont aignan
poutou arthaud avec trente et une voix
nathalie arthaud peu d'abstention 15,77
félicitations aux habitants de viroflay
qui se sont beaucoup déplacé aujourd'hui
alors grandes villes nous avons
nous n'avons pas les anonymes on devrait
pas les féliciter mais on peut aller
voir bordeaux
alors bordeaux non grandes villes un ce
serait peut-être où on a eu de la chance
je revends donc peut-être la purée
winants bordeaux 1 1 % résultat c'est
sûr il est encore un peu tôt pour les
grandes villes mais mon pc par exemple
marseille et on va essayer ces grandes
villes et à mon avis c'est encore un
petit peu tôt et voyez marseille on n'a
pas encore les résultats on va voir lyon
qu'on a vu les résultats pour
saint-etienne à saint-etienne on l'a dit
qu'on y retourne et rêverait en plus
alors lyon ces résultats par
arrondissement par exemple on n'a même
pas les résultats par arrondissement à
lyon alors saint-etienne louis une des
premières grandes communes qu'on nous a
demandé alors c'est toujours un peu
compliqué parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
saint-etienne saint-etienne dans la
loire c'est ici à regarder et n'ont
toujours pas dans ce jeu saint-etienne
malheureusement vont vous voyez les
grandes communes on a eu brest tout à
l'heure on a eu rouen mais il ya
plusieurs grandes communes qu'on n'a pas
eu encore malheureusement on dépend des
résultats du ministère de l'intérieur a
les dizaines de minutes on y va résultat
on a tenté grâce c'est kevin finalement
ça sur jeu grâce à oui je crois que
c'était un prénom grâce ou perturbés
grâce allons-y oui on a les résultats à
grasse
c'est une commune de c
grande importance 48 1865 habitants en
2018 marine le pen en tête à grasse
devant emmanuel macron et donc jean luc
mélenchon eric zemmour est quatrième
avec un score plutôt plutôt meilleur que
ce qu'il fait au niveau national yannick
jadot valérie pécresse jean lassalle est
à peu près dans le même ordre que
d'habitude dupont aignan ou celle
hidalgo poutou arthaud nathalie arthaud
80 une voix abstention assez élevé 29
62% cette commune de grâce je vous
montre pas grave parce que tout le monde
sait que c'est joli et ça va nous donner
envie à mandela dont on est déjà très
indécis c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de
monde qui nous demandent voalavo vos des
résultats vos envies de vacances on
verra ça plus tard donc moi on la rend
tarde pas et on repart tout de suite à
cuers dans le 83 à cuers absolument
allons-y 83 on a vu dans le var on avait
du mal à voir les résultats on sait que
c'est un siècle après c'est dur on a les
résultats cuir bon c'est vrai que c'est
une commune un peu plus petit mais c'est
marine le pen dont qui arrive en tête
34,19 % des voix devant emmanuel macron
et jean luc mélenchon de bons scores
pour marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon
15,92 bon score également pour eric
zemmour dans cette commune du var de
cuers yannick jadot valérie pécresse et
ensuite je laisse défiler jusqu'en bas
pour que tout le monde voit les
résultats de chaque candidat dites-moi
qui nous a demandé qu hier c'est kevin
je crois c'est eva à eva rivas sûr je
n'arrive à voilà si vous étiez vous avez
voté nathalie arthaud seize autres
personnes ont fait comme vous juste en
dessous des va toujours sur youtube on a
émis qui nous demandera à reims à peut
avoir une grande comme jeunes rats ça
peut être un peu moins grand que les
autres communes qu'on a pu chercher de
la quelques instants la marne suspense
insoutenable
rens oui on a les résultats à reims
alors je regarde il ya beaucoup
d'habitants à 182 mille habitants à
reims emmanuel macron est donc en tête
dans sept communes de la marne dans la
préfecture de la marne jean luc
mélenchon et 2e marine le pen est
troisième juste derrière ça c'est serré
quand même entre entre les deux eric
zemmour quatrième yannick jadot et je
fais des filets
les graisses fabien roussel jean
lassalle nicolas dupont aignan et on va
jusqu'en basse et nathalie arthaud qui
se classe regardez une voix de moins que
philippe poutou ils se sont tirés la
bourre tout le monde c'est de là anne
hidalgo 978 voix peut voter à reims
regarder l'abstention elle est quand
même assez ri 32 83% à les cinq minutes
encore on cherche encore un peu on
valorise y en a cinq minutes on va
prendre karine qui nous demandent
châteauroux à châteauroux grande ville
signe à nouveau vous savez ce qu'on va
faire on va faire plaisir si on peut à
des gens qui nous suivent sur youtube à
des gens qui nous suivent sur
lefigaro.fr et à des gens qui nous
suivent sur facebook châteauroux c'est
qui qui nous demandent ce à châteauroux
s'est alors attendez karim non c'est
karim on respecte karine karine karine
pardon j'ai compris karim bonjour karine
bonsoir et à châteauroux regarder dans
votre commune c'est emmanuel macron qui
est en tête devant jean luc mélenchon et
devant marine le pen
le podium est inversée mais les trois
les trois leaders deux sets de 7 ce
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle sont bien en première
place eric zemmour est 4e valérie
pécresse yannick jadot on descend petit
à petit qui arrive en dernière position
c'est toujours le suspense entre souvent
nathalie arthaud et philippe poutou
c'est nathalie arthaud cette fois et là
aussi les grandes villes on sait pas
forcément très bien déplacé 31 %
d'abstention les grandes villes on voit
comme se faire un joli petit village
pour finir si vous avez ça oui alors on
on va tenter ça avec port saint père
port-saint-père 44 710 ah oui et qui
nous demande ça c'est ahmed sur youtube
port saint père
ça s'est fait comme ça attendez est ce
que oui c'est bon j'ai port-saint-père
geforce inter c'est en loire-atlantique
port saint père emmanuel macron en tête
dans ce dans cette ville 503 voix pour
emmanuel macron où je pense que c'est
une ville 503 voix et je veux c'est
trouver combien d'habitants à port saint
père est-ce que je peux trouver ça non
malheureusement j'ai pas encore le gpat
très très rapidement le nombre
d'habitants donc emmanuel macron devant
mélenchon devant le pen voilà pour pour
le trio de tête dans cette ville de port
saint père yannick jadot eric zemmour
valérie pécresse jean lassalle nicolas
dupont aignan fabien roussel anne
hidalgo philippe poutou est donc c'est
nathalie arthaud avec 11 voix qui ferme
la marche bien voter à port-saint-père
18 % d'abstention seulement pour saint
père salaires jolie aussi le nom on voit
le mont corps et qui ça c'est ce que
vous aimez mais pas beaucoup trouvaient
deux villes de montagne je trouve ton je
trouve
alors allons-y
on s'en doute une petite commune quoique
la roche sur foron a alors là vous me
fait plaisir la roche-sur-foron c'est en
haute savoie la voilà parce que depuis
le début de ce live en une petite
guéguerre lui ne me donne que des noms
de villes bretonnes parce qu'il est
breton et moi je réclame des villes et
des villages de haute savoie alors la
roche sur foron on y est on a
11175 habitants et on a les résultats la
roche-sur-foron vous voyez quand vous
voulez vous pouvez être agréablement
cher à rien emmanuel macron 28% des voix
dans cette commune devant jean-luc
mélenchon score un peu plus faible pour
marine le pen 18,38 qui nous demandent
salars sur fond la réchauffement clm
beats sur youtube elle n 8 lm 8l mbits
beats un vide à corps et biens on le
salue ce haut-savoyard je le salue tout
particulièrement vous ne les aimez pas
j'ai bien compris on a bien voté 21 91 %
d'abstention seulement à la roche sur
foron selon me trouve un breton pour
vous venger d'un an et j'avais thibault
j'aime tellement peu les savoyards qu'on
va prendre velandia / / / facebook et
nous n'en ait à annecy grandes villes
annecy la haute-savoie évidemment deux
villes de suite en savoie voulait me
faire plaisir et on a les résultats
aussi en 628 milles 199 habitants
mais l'écologiste
ainsi emmanuel macron est en tête devant
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
seulement seulement troisièmes avec un
petit score et regarder yannick jadot
ifaw score à l'écologie dans cette ville
dans cette ville alors c'est vrai que la
haute savoie c'est une terre de droite
mais eric zemmour et valérie pécresse
sont pas des très bons scores là non
plus dit qu'on ait du poignant jean
lassalle anne hidalgo non pas sous les
1% avec philippe poutou et nathalie
arthaud abstention assez faible allez à
faible par rapport au niveau national 23
% d'abstentionnistes annecy
alors est ce qu on s comprend
commentaires de théo qui nous dit oui
dites moi et puis pendant ce temps à
regarder je vous montre ce que c'est
aussi une formidable ville quand même la
venise des alpes dites moi le
commentaire donnez-nous les résultats de
marseille
on peut mais j'ai déjà cherché comment
je vous montre un 2,6 alors marseille
c'est une trop grande ville ont
peut-être j'ai cherché il ya un petit
quart d'heure on retente aise est ce que
en un quart d'heure ce serait miraculeux
mais allons dit essayons marseille
marseille on attend encore les résultats
malheureusement c'est non non non c'est
une trop grande mais deuxième de france
en terme de population c'est trop
compliqué mais ce commentaire mais tu es
fort sympathique c'est vrai ça va c'est
vrai que peut-on choisir
mathieu demande aurillac aurillac
d'accord alors orientée dans le cantal
aurillac il semblerait dans le 15 mai
c'est ça c'est le cantal aurillac 30 2%
pour emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon
est en deuxième position juste devant
marine le pen 19 18 c'est assez serré
c'est valérie pécresse qui est donc en
4e position eric zemmour est 5e et puis
on descend petit à petit avec nathalie
arthaud 65 voix aurillac une abstention
les moyennes nationales 24,5 pour cent
des voix on a encore beaucoup de
commentaires ou pas combien on en
convient on en fait fausse tu te fixes
arrêtera jamais ça allez faisons en deux
ou trois à l'e3 vous savez quoi je sers
le groupe 5 allée sa part comprend les
on prend les 5 qui arrive alors nous
avons sur facebook d'orient qui nous
demande tu regarde vraiment comment ça
s'écrit heurter huerre ck
hch
alors est-ce qu'on est surpris que ce
soit en alsace et un an de lille comme
ça pas vraiment 21 ans à turckheim 812
voix pour emmanuel macron qui est en
tête avec un bon score à 34,33 % des
voix le podium national est le même à
turckheim 23 89 pour marine le pen
mélenchon jean luc à 13% et règlement
est quatrième devant yannick jadot c'est
assez serré 19 voix d'écart valérie
pécresse nicolas dupont aignan tient à
4,10 pour son c'est plutôt un bon score
pour lui jean lassalle anne hidalgo
philippe poutou fallait roussel c'est
nathalie arthaud faire la marche 14 voix
à 23 75 % d'abstention c'est plutôt pas
mal les gens ont bien voté à turckheim
alors là nous avons toujours sur youtube
à l'embaumement partant d'été sur
facebook ton corps passe sur youtube -
maastricht ça qui nous demandent où
l'ins ou l'unss alors il ya un par un au
1o eu et ses deux ailes i ls
oui alors vous avez vu qu'il ya un ou
deux ans je vous laisse avec un seul l
et oui c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas se
tromper alors regardez on va aller sur
roullens dans le rhône ou l'ins emmanuel
macron est arrivé en tête 28,20 % des
voix devant jean-luc mélenchon très
serrée 1 il ya 39 voix d'écart
précisément je sais pas si vous voyez le
petit chiffre main ici sous le score
marine le pen et 3e 14,81 2% des voix
yannick jadot tient quatrième position
7% juste devant eric zemmour et puis on
descend vous avez l'ensemble des
résultats à olemps ou l'instant le rhône
c'est qui nous a demandé ça
c'était maastricht sa stricte alors vous
savez qu'on peut taper par exemple le
code postal ainsi il ya trop de
saint-etienne par exemple on sait on a
vu où on est on a eu des envies des
embêtements avec saint-etienne vous
tapez le code postal et vous tombez
directement sur la ville c'est tout à
fait possible vous pouvez le faire chez
vous sur trouvé cette page des résultats
sur la page d'accueil du figaro dites
moi on a autre chose plus que quatre
allez plus que 4 on a quatre chanceux
fumic chiot sur youtube tourcoing à
tourcoing allons-y allons à tourcoing là
aussi on est dans le nord et c'est jean
luc mélenchon tient qui est en tête dans
dans cette commune de tourcoing qui est
quand même une municipalité importante à
combien on a d'habitants j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas à voir combien d'habitants
alors je redescends rapidement 36%
marine le pen ou de rien est quasiment
le même score que emmanuel macron ya le
calcul de tête 14 voix d'écart seulement
entre les deux candidats du qualifié
pour le second tour eric zemmour on suit
tout de suite 4 62% yannick jadot
valérie pécresse fabien roussel non m'at
il fait pas un bon score malheureusement
même si on sait qu'il a été plutôt bon
quand on a cherché des communes dans le
nord et dans le pas de calais c'est
nathalie arthaud qui ferme la voix
regardez l'abstention l'aller très élevé
à tourcoing 38,37 % c'est comme à
roubaix tout à l'heure où on avait plus
de 40% c'est pas la plus élevée mais
c'est lui
les plus absolument aller on va prendre
ahmed sûr
du soir à metz dit mme
charland chalon ch à 2 et la n est ce
pas la pâte et l'uil chalon par hasard
challans comment vous écrivez
avec deux ailes à c'est pour ça que je
trouve pas seulement exactement 7 en
vendée challans emmanuel macron là aussi
en tête avec un joli écart 1 35 29 % il
a fait la différence à challans devant
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon qui
fait un score beaucoup plus faible qu'au
niveau national eric zemmour est en
quatrième position devant valérie
pécresse et yannick jadot et puis
ensuite vous voyez les autres résultats
ahmed si vous avez voté pour nathalie
arthaud vous êtes l'un des rares à
l'avoir fait 84 voix pour pour la
candidate de lutte ouvrière 24 40 %
d'abstention à challans plus trois
communes qui seront les heureux élus
avaient bien ça sera ton art gagne
compiegne compiegne allons-y à compiègne
trouvons les résultats 40000 habitants
donc c'est une ville importante et on a
les résultats à compiègne ou emmanuel
macron est donc en tête 29 50 % des voix
devant jean-luc mélenchon il fait un bon
score jean luc mélenchon à compiègne
dans l'oise voisins aussi beaucoup de
communes de l'oise beaucoup de gens nous
en demande et merci à eux marine le pen
eric zemmour valérie pécresse yannick
jadot je fais défiler jusqu'en bas on n'
ostensions importante un plus de 30 %
d'abstention à compiègne on verra ce qui
se passe au deuxième tour parce que la
semaine prochaine on est là on a dit
combien plus que deux maintenant google
donc à l'aller l'avant-dernière l'on va
faire une grande ville et après je vais
vraiment essayer de chercher une petite
commune d'accord à vous le pensez vous
êtes un amoureux de territoire exact
allez on va on va tenter chartres
chartres ouais c'est repos s'ils sont
confirmés
je suis assez confiant attention je
m'avance peut être en eure-et-loir
attend les résultats à chartres oui non
oui on a les résultats achats c'est
emmanuel macron qui est en tête dans
sept communes devant jean-luc mélenchon
et marine le pen eric zemmour est
quatrième devant valérie pécresse à peu
près le même score tous les deux yannick
jadot et fait plus de 5% à chartres et
puis ensuite nicolas dupont aignan anne
hidalgo fabien roussel jean lassalle
philippe poutou est une fois de plus
nathalie arthaud j'ai l'impression que
nathalie arthaud est
souvent dernier dans plusieurs communes
30 % d'abstention à chartres voilà pour
les résultats dans cette commune doré
loire c'est la dernière ouais c'était
donc là c'était nolwenn qui nous
demandait ça sur facebook et arrive en
regrettant de faire notre dernière
aurait capitulé parce que je suis se
récuser allez pas me faire bon alors on
a fait un petit classement depuis le
début de la soirée pour savoir la ville
au nom le plus rigolo est le grand
gagnant et glandage vous confirmez lie
apple il y avait vraiment de compétition
alors là oui c'est vrai on nous on
essayait de nous transmettre et nous
demande de chercher la ville de montcuq
on a fait évidemment mais c'était un peu
comme un un peu attendu donc on félicite
la personne ne se souvient plus du
prénom qui nous avait demandés la ville
de glandage on félicite aussi le plus
joli pseudo match et je reste sur la
plante verte oui oui on a dit on a élu
mais là on est catastrophe et il drink
dream thimoté pas mal pas mal c'est le
podium et fait mes plantes vertes quand
même parce qu'on imagine mon la plus
petite commune seulement 4
quatre électeurs possible trois votants
trois votants qui n'ont pas voté pareil
hein pour marine le pen 1 pour jean luc
mélenchon 1 pour emmanuel macron 1 pour
eric zemmour il me semble et donc c'est
le mesnil mitri qui l'emportent on n'a
pas fait plus petit nom et teddy les
plus jolis prénoms en a longtemps été
sur la chaussée victor et si on se met
d'accord vous étiez très amoureux et du
nom de saint flour de mercoire
magnifique petite commune en tout cas ou
non magnifique de saint flour de
mercoire vrai que c'était en lozère à
une simple vu sa tête à l'envers voilà
pour notre classement du sort on
essaiera de faire mieux la semaine
prochaine et dont il est la dernière
commune que l'on cherche ce soir et pour
qui alors ce sera pour eux the way
selman sur youtube folman qui nous
demande castanet tolosan castanet
tolosan alors c'est vers toulouse
castanet tolosan évidemment sans aucun
doute castanet tolosan exact on y est on
y est et les résultats à castanet
tolosan ville de 13 1811 habitants qui
aura la chance de conclure cela il ce
soir et c'est donc emmanuel macron qui
arrivait en tête avec 29 46% des voix je
les détailler ses résultats parce que
castanet tolosan est la dernière ville
qu'on suivra ce soir jean luc mélenchon
26,86 devant marine le pen 14
63% des voix lennik jadot est donc 4e au
pied du podium eric zemmour valérie
pécresse jean lassalle anne hidalgo
fabien roussel nicolas dupont aignan
philippe poutou et nathalie arthaud qui
récolte à castanet tolosan 26% des voix
dans une commune et on les applaudit
applaudissent y aller parce qu'ils ont
bien voté 16 52 2% des voix ça vous
allait rien ouais très bien bon expliqué
parce que s'il y en a qui nous
rejoignent peut-être maintenant ce qu'on
a fait et on rappelle qu on sera là
aussi la semaine prochaine comment ça
marchait et qui on remercie parce que
c'est vous qui savez tous ces gens qui
nous ont aidés oui alors on a utilisé
cet outil dont il a été développé au
sein du figaro donc un moteur de
recherche dans lequel vous pouvez taper
le nom de votre commune pour trouver les
résultats donc pendant plus de deux
heures sur facebook sur lefigaro.fr sur
youtube vous nous avez
tout simplement vous avez tapé le nombre
de communes et le numéro du département
et thibault s'est fait un plaisir de de
vous montrer les résultats et les
commenter alors en très bonne compagnie
j'ai rien merci nono alors disons le
c'est pas un outil interne vous pouvez y
avoir accès vous aussi évidemment donc
il est sur le site du figaro.fr on
rappelle aussi que vous pouvez vous
inscrire parce que peut-être que ce soir
vous avez demandé le nom de votre
commune vous habitez dans une grande
ville on n'a pas forcément eu les
résultats pouvaient soit rentré votre
votre adresse email certainement figaro
si vous avez l'application du figaro ça
marche aussi bien la télécharger vous
conseille de télécharger vous pouvez
rentrer le nom de votre commune et vous
avez une notification sur le téléphone
qui arrive quand les résultats sont
disponibles
et donc vous remercie par les
développeurs du figaro et le ministère
de l'intérieur qui nous a transmis ces
chiffres on les a pas inventé évidemment
et on sait le même outil qu'on utilisera
pour le second tour voilà le voici il
est là on a pu tous ensemble essayer de
trouver les résultats continuer à vous
le faites chez vous vous trouvez ce site
on remercie tout le monde merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine merci a tous passé une bonne
soirée et donc on rappelle que emmanuel
macron et marine le pen sont qualifiés
pour le second tour merci excellente
soirée à bientôt à la semaine prochaine
on fait la même chose et puis évidemment
un pendant ces deux semaines ont
continué à suivre la politique et puis
toutes les autres actualités sur figaro
live salut merci